see if this works
this is the most technology i've used
outside of the atacama desert
but hopefully all will be well
and we should be going live on youtube
as we speak yes there we are hello
everybody
listening out
on youtube on twitter spaces
in the multiverse in the metaverse i
think this is quite
uh quite fun to do we should take
advantage of all the good technology and
bring together good friends and people
of goodwill and good faith
and so with that in mind i wanted to
close out the month of december the year
that was 2021
with a uh with one of my best friends i
won't say oldest friends i will say one
of my best looking friends
and that is the way he needs to be
addressed
and that is of course dr eric weinstein
let me bring him in over here how are
you sir you are now brian good to be
with you it's great to be with you
and we have a lot of people watching all
over the universe
and i wanted to uh first kind of give
you uh some hearty congratulations
because you have had a really
significant year of many accomplishments
and we're going to get into those
accomplishments
in particular you have just recently i
noticed joined the research wing of the
uh so-called galileo project or project
galileo led by mutual friend uh
professor avi loeb a man who is not
shy from controversy and i want to ask
you
um what was your decision making walk me
through the process that led to you
um
really
joining up joining forces and partnering
with an institution that you don't
necessarily have a lot of love uh for
but well that's not fair
okay so talk us through the process
yeah i believe that uh
in essence uh there there's a story
about the the night i ate a plate full
of sauteed mushrooms at isidore singer's
house because i couldn't figure out how
to say
that i wasn't an adult to his lovely
wife rosemary um
and i feel like with ufos i really i
came to hate the topic while growing up
never took an interest wasn't a big
science fiction person
and
then you know i gradually found that
people around me who i thought well of
uh were taking this more seriously than
i was and
i found that the ridicule that uh that i
would was reflexively
doling out for the topic was being met
with different sorts of answers by some
people i should say that there's a
subset of ufo land that's just crazy
um but there are
there's been a huge shift um and no
matter what this is anything from psyop
to uh
you know our future selves are visiting
us in the past in a crazy universe that
has physics we don't understand yet
whatever it is
it's being taken seriously enough by our
pentagon it's being taken seriously
enough by people in
positions um
where they have some sort of security
clearance for me to say i want
to take this black box seriously because
i don't know what's in it and that
includes the possibility of a
psychological operation or you know
we're trying to come up with a cover
story because we've got advanced tech we
don't want the
our adversaries to know about
but it's completely irresponsible um
to take the position that i was taking
at this point
uh this is no longer the loch ness
monster and then you know you have the
problem of like now do i have to take
the loch ness monster seriously uh you
know the idea that this is coupled to
people who do remote viewing the whole
thing seems very unsavory and because of
the luxurious position i'm in where
um
i trust my relationship uh with my
employer at a level that i've never
trusted an employer before
that could end up being being my undoing
but i think that it's important that
people with certain kinds of credentials
take this seriously to take a lead to
destigmatize it and i'm i'm
i see i hear you uh there your camera
seems to be frozen that's true
um
so let us uh hmm yeah this has happened
um we are now muted on youtube at least
on eric's side so we'll try to patch
this up just as you were talking about
you know interlopers and so forth uh
there you are you're back now we have a
camera view of your coffee cup
back live
hmm
mm-hmm
uh so let's work on your camera again
eric it's frozen or
and it's pointed a little too low
uh
oh uh okay
um are you able to
log back out log back in that seemed to
do it before
um
so we've you know i've noticed this year
i've done you know i'm also an advisor
an external advisor to avi loeb's uh uh
so-called project galileo and i i you
know if i could have asked
avi to consider one thing before he went
ahead with the naming of it i always
find it perilous when uh astronomers
compare themselves to either you know
galileo or or giodarno bruno all these
great
astronomers who met untimely fortunes in
in one sense or another um i i find that
is not entirely helpful but on the other
hand what he's trying to do beyond just
the you know hopeful avoid the the the
awful end that galileo had um is to use
data to investigate phenomena that if
real would fall under the purview of uh
of you know some aspects of the uh of
the standard model of physics
uh let's see eric is back here let's see
now you're in the green room let me add
you to the right there you go
so we see you now very good um so i was
just saying eric you know
if if galileo's to be taken seriously
hopefully it's not the way he was you
know threatened with torture but uh but
rather that he was using data for the
very first time
to assay or check and we'll get into
assaying and stuff later uh laws of
nature using instruments that he built
to you know do what he said to do was to
make uh to measure what's measurable and
make measurable what is not so i want to
ask you
uh what do you think is possible to
measure that we have not been able to
make measurable yet are there
technologies or is it just more of the
same with optical telescopes radio
telescopes etc or do you think it's
going to require a technological advance
that we're not currently capable of
well
so i keep thinking about the three
long-range fields that we've used for
teloscopy the photon the neutrino
and the gravity wave and
i think that if you think about this in
terms of known physics it's really
interesting to me to watch our
colleagues talk about what is possible
and what is impossible assuming that the
theories we have now are not effective
theories but are fundamental theories so
a number of people will say things like
well so and so is impossible by the laws
of relativity and you would say well
it's impossible within relativity but if
you were to try to describe let's say
lorentz contraction or time dilation
inside of newtonian physics you'd have
all sorts of surprises in store for you
same thing with trying to figure out
double slit experiments from a newtonian
perspective
so in part we don't know what theories
are to come and i think one of the
things that i've come to understand
about the whole ufo uap controversy
controversy
is that it's really very different if
you imagine that you are getting your
physics from
technology that was constructed by
civilizations that you don't know
anything about which is you know what
you're talking about in the most
optimistic uap scenario ufo
what you're doing is you're looking at
somebody's engineered craft it's like
you're trying to understand radio waves
by looking at a radio
rather than looking at radio waves by
looking at the electromagnetic spectrum
and i think that that has given this
field a very weird feel to it it means
that our aerospace corporations are much
more deep in the weeds in what would
normally be science than we expect i
think one of the things that i've
learned
is that our government doesn't trust
open scientific culture that for a brief
period of time you could get a bunch of
physicists to keep mom more or less out
in the desert
during world war ii but this is in
general not
a trusted paradigm and so in part what
we're doing is we're working with a lot
of people who are sort of physics
adjacent like electrical engineers
or material science people so maybe some
of that is is uh physics but it's not
the right neighborhood of physics for
the interstellar intergalactic travel
part of this
and there is a just a dearth of uh
high-level physics talent
and sort of differential geometric
talent who is who are looking at
this question because for some reason um
we don't take it very seriously
yeah quite honestly i'm very sympathetic
with the fact that we are bigoted and
don't take it very seriously because it
sounds completely goofy right right yeah
even the the kind of
scene that was shown last night uh with
um you know on uh i don't know if it was
today or something like that
where uh the uh the newscaster started
off the broadcast with uh with the
x-files and
you know and it's like if you're trying
to make this uh take this as seriously
as as you and i believe it should be uh
taken then you know connecting it to you
know the the theme song or the theme
of a of a television show that was i
want to believe i mean do you want to
believe in things eric as a scientist
how do you reconcile that well let's put
it this way my life is not so dull that
i need aliens to liven it up
right um but let's take three different
topics that i think are important
uh
unidentified aircraft in military
airspaces
let's say
second one would be psychedelics and
healing
and the third one would be human
sexuality and in particular porn
you'll notice that there's a giggle on
each one of them
and as a result you have these forces
that are completely
you know potentially altering our
civilization in various ways we could be
doing a great job of healing with
psychedelics and yet we're still
laughing about oh so and so was tripping
you know
that kind of nonsense uh
and it's not terrible to tell sex jokes
or to tell drug jokes it's just that
there's got to be a way
to send the kids to bed so that you can
actually have a serious conversation
about these things and one of the
problems that we're having is is that
the public sphere
is pervaded by a certain ethos a culture
which i've sometimes called the degraded
state where you're just sort of snarking
and
you're let making trivial jokes uh and
you're meaning and you're calling it
awesome and you're saying oh you don't
get the internet
and it's like well actually maybe you
don't get life in the opportunity that
we have that earnestness probably is
trading at a discount
and if we were to take
um psychedelics more seriously like how
many special forces guys who risked
their lives for our country could we
save if we got some of these drugs off
of schedule one where they don't belong
hey am i like psychedelics or whatever
yeah i'm talking about lsd and dmt
things that will cause people to raise
an eyebrow right the idea that these
things are not therapeutic or have a
high potential for harm has been
disproven yet they sit there on a list
which clearly has those as its twin
criteria
um
doesn't make any sense the the porn
explosion uh is a serious epidemic and
we're not talking about what it really
means whether it's sex positive which it
is in part and whether it's destroying
lives which it is in part
why because we can't get through it
without laughing and i think the same
thing is true with uap it's like oh the
truth is out there oh tin foil hat oh my
god flying sauce would you shut up i
just don't know i don't know what to do
with it it's like these are the serious
issues of our lives our pentagon
released a report and if if if it is
that just them having a few yucks you
know hey i got it we'll put out a report
and we'll talk about ufos um
i i think we scientists should follow it
down just the way the amazing randy did
yeah the problem is you know i had a
live stream with my friend kurt
jaimungle our mutual friend who is
somewhere in the chat room i hope and uh
was with tom delong and
this former cia operative named jimmy
semivan and
i got a lot of heat for that one uh from
a lot of people that watch my show how
can a legitimate scientist entertain
this uh and then i had on you know you
and then a skeptic like michael shermer
together just after the you know prior
to the pentagon report in june and we
want to get to that and you know so i
get it from all sides but one one thing
you know i haven't asked
you know besides you and and michael i
would have back on you know i i don't
know if i'd have you know tom delonge on
in other words i think i extracted you
know as a as a ufologist would do you
know extracted all the kind of
interesting content from i think he's a
great guy he's funny you know i'd love
to hang out go skateboarding and play
music with him or at least play spotify
you know that's the only thing i can
play uh unlike you uh but uh but i found
it very kind of um unsatisfying that
that you know kind of the evidence that
he was presenting and including the the
remains of congress
let's be efficient about it
what's really going on is something
different which is that people aren't
actually listening to try to figure out
what's being said you're trying to say
tell me the minimal thing i can hear
from you so i know i never have to
listen to you ever again
and that's been confused now with like
it's it's not the scientific method it's
the internet method right and the
internet method is like i just want you
to say something dumb that i can maybe
maybe if i have to i'll take it out of
context but almost everyone has brain
farts or they lie or you know they get
caught in something and then the idea is
can i just put that on repeat so i never
have to see you or hear from you again
and i think that that's
a large portion of what science has been
doing i don't want to respond to crazy
people who say
hey i'm bending spoons in my garage and
you know i've been abducted and you have
to check out all of my claims
uh because i have a warp drive that'll
get us out of here why are you ignoring
me like that person writes to me
well okay so we need better ways of
dismissing
claims
that aren't this whole sale you can't
talk to somebody like one of the things
that we have is in the neo-darwinian
world
we have a claim no creationist paper has
ever passed peer review
okay
so you're staking everything on the idea
that you have a filter and that nothing
has ever gotten through the filter
well what if somebody does a pretty
terrific
study of something
and then they leave the door open to
creationism
are there is
are we gonna lose the science because
they made an off-hand remark at the end
of their paper that maybe we have to
rethink things and it could be
you know it could it might not even be a
creationist paper as soon as you come up
with these rules like
you know no scientist has ever done it's
it's an it's a desire for artificial
cleanliness is what it is
and i think that what we've got to
recognize is that a lot of the people
that you see
who are giving you this heat are coming
at it from this different perspective
which is i want omuamua to go away i
want
avi loeb taking the series i wanted to
say he's a careerist and that this is
just an attempt to get money
and i understand where that's coming
from but it's also an incredibly
destructive
impulse i mean can you imagine if when
benjamin jesse uh took
uh cow puss and stuck it into his family
uh to try to keep them safe from
smallpox what would be said about him on
twitter right or as you and i have said
you know with james clerk maxwell's
maxwell's equations
that were propagated by gears and
vortices and of course an ether
and let alone it made great advances and
actually in cosmology our hands aren't
as clean as those wonderful darwinian
evolutionary macro evolutionary because
we publish many many papers on the
steady state the quasi-steady state uh
all sorts of other things in addition to
things like the multiverse
which our friend and mutual uh ew ed
whitton has come to apparently
uh learn to love this is crazy i mean i
don't know how people are following this
story yeah
i can summarize the multiverse
perspective if you want to talk about
the landscape or at least the string
theory aspects of it which are very good
when are you uh
i'll use a britishism you're very brave
brian perhaps you should go first
or maybe uh edward is is following uh
this conversation
i doubt it too he he only seems to
follow you know things that are uh
negative about israel uh but but be that
as it may if he's out there he's always
welcome uh uh to come on i um noted
there was a cern courier which is one of
the most prestigious you know kind of
non-journal type journals that is a must
read uh that he had an interview and
kind of commemorating um uh i i forget
exactly what the what the uh occasion
was but he was kind of reflecting on you
know 25 years since
maybe i don't know uh the the
uh miracle or something like that or the
construction of cern and he was saying
uh you know how much of of of his
perspective has changed and in one sense
he said very little it's been so
spectacular successful the standard
model is very hard to break and to make
progress and of course the interview
asked him about uh about the you know
his thoughts on things like uh the
string theory landscape which postulates
that you know for uh for all the
different possible vacuum configurations
there are corresponding uh different
constants of nature laws of physics
perhaps even
and and this is known as the landscape
and and uh or the swamp land depending
on who you talk to and it has a very
direct correspondence and some say
that's a good thing i think it's kind of
frightening actually but to the
multiverse of cosmology which is
postulated by
uh logical extrapolation from inflation
theory so he's now saying that you know
he used to not like these anthropic kind
of arguments but you know he's learned
to kind of adapt to them and adjust to
them as as part of natural and natural
expectation and you know basically we
should stop telling the universe what to
do
but as one person said you know it's not
just giving up like if you're gonna just
adopt the multiverse or the landscape as
a possibility
then you know what what point is there
in doing physics at this point so how
did you react to that interview uh you
know that that i sent down
oh boy so first of all let's let's say
the positive part which is that um
i think there was an old
view that nobody holds anymore which
said that if we could just understand
the law maybe maybe pre-laplace
if we just understand the laws of nature
we could compute its consequences and
know the future
and
i think that this strong reductionism
doesn't really exist it's a straw man in
our day and age
everyone now understands that some of
the properties of the world are sort of
properties of the equations or for the
few physicists in the audience the
lagrangian
some parts of this
have to do
with the
solutions of the equations that certain
solutions of the equations have certain
properties that we think of as normal
but there are other solutions that we
know nothing about and so we we are
stuck in a subset of the solutions and
some of this has to do with um
you know what might be a confusion that
we should be on the lookout for you
think that there's a number that means
something but that number is actually
the value of a field that changes in
space and time so i might say that i'm
kind of chilly in this room it's
probably 64 degrees in here something
like that but it's not a uniform number
it's a number that changes depending
upon where i am in the room and if i
said that the the temperature in the
room is 64 degrees i would be making
this confusion in a way that's very easy
to understand
so i think that there's a lot of room
for kind of humility and discipline with
respect to saying i wonder what part of
this is anthropic what part of this is a
property of the solutions which is part
of the equations what is a vacuum
expectation value that is actually a
field that has been excited to some
level that is reasonably constant where
we live et cetera et cetera so i think
that's all healthy and positive
and i think it's great that he said that
the part that i don't like is wait a
minute you just took the entire field of
physics on a nearly 40-year
adventure
where which was characterized in the
early portion by getting rid of your
competitors by saying we'll have the
whole thing wrapped up by noontime
tomorrow because they're only you know
a finite number of theories to
investigate and nothing else has the
power and glory of string theory all
who can see it will be healed amen i
mean
the crimes of string theorists are very
different than the issues with string
theory string theory is not going to
hurt anybody it's a bunch of equations
and ideas and complex of stuff but when
you have people
you know even that we respect like
maddie cyberg saying oh if
string theory will be right because if
anyone comes up with anything that isn't
string theory we'll call it string
theory right and you're thinking like
well that's
are you allowed to say that i think that
what we need to do is to recognize that
collegiality in academics is a resource
and
what academics looks like in the absence
of collegiality where you're just full
hunger games and you and you announce
your strategy hey you know i i only
invited you to dinner so that i could
i could execute you and eat you you know
well wait what you know i i have this
very strong negative feeling so you're
telling me we should work on something
and then if we get it right and you have
it wrong you'll just call it what you
were doing to begin with and you're
announcing this to the world it's sort
of a joke but it really isn't um i think
that there's something about string
theory
that it's an enormous complex of
interrelated ideas that clearly
means something we don't know what it
means and what it means may not be about
physics what it means may be about pure
mathematics infinite dimensional
structures extended objects all this
stuff
um we when we found out that quantum
field theory wasn't about physics in the
80s
it was a complete shock to me and it
didn't seem to register to too many
people that when when topological
quantum field theory came out it was
very similar to what happened with
adscft
sort of a decade later
which is that
you connected things that showed that
what you were working on didn't mean
what you said so for example with
strings it was claimed that string
theory could do things that gauge
theories couldn't
but then if you have some sort of
holographic principle or duality
principle or any kind of a principle
that says oh this string theory is dual
to a gauge theory you just sort of
undercut your own argument
um
much the way uh you know in my opinion
when we found out that topological
quantum field theories existed they
didn't have anything to do with physics
they had to do with the formal structure
and it was very much like liberating
calculus
from wherever it was initially
discovered in the sciences turns out
calculus is useful for everything
um so you know you might invent let's
say quaternions or something for a very
particular purpose but once you've
invented it
it belongs to the world and i believe
that partially what we found out
is is that
the justification for string theory
has somewhat evaporated um which is
maybe gauge theories can do what string
theories can do maybe there are
dualities and relationships and
holographic principles and
correspondences
that
are much richer and that maybe string
theory is hanging together in a certain
mathematical sense not because it has
anything to do with the physical world
it could be hanging together because
it's a piece of pure mathematics much
the way you know quadratic reciprocity
is true but it doesn't need to come from
the physical
uh world as we know it yeah when i look
back again you know it's always
dangerous when physicists talk about
history or philosophy or religion
uh but but i think you know when they're
sober
we shouldn't be you know forbidden to
talk about it but we should do so
judiciously
and you know and i look at uh you know
some of these comments and and i've had
the honor and pleasure of you know
talking to many people over the past
couple of years since i started this uh
project and i keep coming back to this
question of you know what of what and
i'm not the first to do this obviously
if you know feynman said i don't care
how beautiful your theory is if it
doesn't agree with experiment it's wrong
but eric we're in a situation where
they're you know we're told that the
experiments don't exist they can't exist
we can't make them
and i often say you know look if i told
ed whitton you know in
1971 when he was working you know right
next door to frank wilcek uh was it 73
uh well graduate school in 70. oh yeah
wrong oh really okay well yeah you know
he was working on the mcgovern campaign
anyway keep going
again uh so i retract what i said about
physicists in history because uh
obviously i'm talking i'm a podcaster
you're an internet celebrity um and i
said well what if i told you back then
you know we'll have these colliders but
they won't collide you know protons and
anti-protons or electron electron
scattering no they'll collide
you know
entities made up of 10 to the 56
neutrons together uh two of them you
know 30 solar mass uh neutron stars or
whatever multi multi solar mass neutron
we'll collide them together at a few
times the speed a few percent of the
speed of light uh would you take that
you know would that be enough to tell
you would they have said at that point
eric no we need something beyond the lhc
i mean that's an interesting question
yeah i mean what what do we make of this
you know because a theorist will hide
let me say this an experimentalist will
hide our results i'm speaking on behalf
of myself only we often hide our uh i
wouldn't say dirty laundry but we'll
hide behind the upper limit so what is
an upper limit an upper limit is saying
you know we're not going to put a stake
in the ground we made a detection uh you
know we we know it's not bigger than a
certain value and and so therefore you
know we don't have to do quite as much
to rule out or to rule out other
competitive explanations because it's
consistent with noise and so you don't
spend your time you know seeing what
other sources of noise you you account
for the systematic noise the statistical
noise and then you're done with an upper
limit a detection is different now i
think the corresponding complementary
perspective as frank wilcheck would call
it is when a theorist says oh we can't
know unless you tell us either the
vacuum state
of our own theory or you build us the
future future galactic pan galactic
collider so i think physics has a
problem in that we have a courage
problem and we're not really willing to
go out and say
that's impossible or you know the the
fruit on the apple tree is way too high
to be picked
got it um couple things first of all so
your first it was a [ __ ] your first
point was a cryptic reference to
um i think ligo and what we can pick up
now that's right uh
i should point out that murray gelman as
early as 1983 at the second shelter
island conference is very clear in his
keynote speech that
we should be using cosmic rays and the
debris from the universe
as a
substitute accelerator
you know in some sense a more powerful
but less predictable one you get what
you get you can't schedule
these uh collisions between black holes
the way you'd like to uh so getting beam
time is kind of a weird thing uh if if
you know that reference i i would say
that the um
you know the the issue
is what we we talked about before the
reason nobody wants to say sharp things
is this idea of
uh and i'm going to bring it back to
feynman because i'm having a weird beef
not with feynman so much but with the
fact that the internet has devol has a
discerned a lot of meaning from him
which is just wrong he was playing to
the cheap seats
i think that he made a lot of very
simple powerful statements which people
love because they don't they're not very
difficult to understand but they're also
not correct
so one of them one of them is is that if
your theory doesn't
agree with your ex
experiments
it's wrong
well no that's not true i mean the issue
is the instance of your theory the
instantiation of your theory is wrong
provided that the experiment was in fact
done correctly and there is that
discrepancy
but i i think that what we're
we really haven't acknowledged this
point we've developed this very bad
habit of the going after the kill shot
you know blas cabrera saw a monopole in
his laboratory on valentine's day in
1990 yeah so and but it's never happened
again so he can't be trusted what's next
right right
right exactly and then the next one is
like oh the string theorists they said
that they were going to do everything
and they didn't do anything
check promise super symmetry from the
lhc run one what about gordon kane
yeah
like and the answer is this is
ridiculous and it's unbecoming it just
it shows that we're not really a science
at the moment um can you imagine if qed
was wrong quantum electrodynamics was
wrong because dirac uh you know got this
prediction of the proton and the
electron wrong
this is dumb it would it would take out
einstein it basically is a rebellion
against and i'm gonna be like not so
nice
it's it's a rebellion like by the
copyright by the copywriters against the
authors
it's like oh if i can find a spelling
error then i can throw out hamlet
oh really oh i didn't know that's how
science works so thanks for the
information i think it's really
important that we stop trying to go
after string theory
i think string theory is not going to
hurt anybody the key issue is string
theory culture and the thing that i'm
really
against
is the idea that we don't want to say
certain things we are all so thankful
that edwin passed through that we don't
want to talk about the fact that he
probably made a disastrous bet veering
the field towards string theory in a
very unconcentrated portfolio of
approaches
and yeah wait wait it's not it's not an
anti-edwin point
if you ask me what you know the closest
i get to an anti-edwin point is why
aren't you taking responsibility
for what you did
to the field right now it needs to be
wide open it needs lots of different
people and i think that the string
theorists have a persistent sort of
complaint which is none of the rest of
you have taken the issues
of renormalizability and compatibility
of gravity with the standard model as
seriously as we have and therefore we
don't trust you with the car keys
and i think that you know in some level
well maybe you guys didn't take
seriously enough the idea that this
wasn't really beautiful
like the argument that this is also
beautiful has empowered our friend
sabina
to go on an anti-beauty tirade that has
really nothing to do with anything um
it's just that the strength theory is
string theorists used
beauty
as a disaster sound
oh no did you do something
hello
i'm not hearing you anywhere you hear me
at all or youtube
um
is your phone
acting up
all right we lost them so i want to i'll
take just a second to chime in with two
you know for every feynman quote there's
an equal and opposite finement quote and
in addition to his saying when he won
the nobel prize that if i could explain
it to you it wouldn't be worth a nobel
prize
he's also rumored to have said
that if you can't explain it to your
grandmother then you don't understand it
so which one was it so eric i see
i know i don't see you i hear you i
think on twitter can you say something
here
eric can you hear me
eric i hear rustling on
at least on twitter spaces but i don't
hear
uh and i've lost you on youtube
now i hear myself
so people are saying yeah i can hear you
on twitter now yep
okay
oh yeah there we go
ah stable enough i see i see you uh i
hear you on twitter let me turn it down
let me see do i just see you right here
youtube say something again
can you hear are you yeah i hear
catching this yeah i hear you now i
think it's fine uh folks can you say
anything uh else uh can you let us know
out there if you can hear us there we go
eric can you hear me
yeah awesome okay so we're talking about
edwin and i i do want to make one
comment i want to get your reaction to
this because
um i have a guest coming up by the name
of christopher sweat who is kind of a
philosopher he's
an intellectual but he he's
african-american and he hates this
notion of black intellectuals
he hates to have uh you know there be
thought of of this you know who is
speaking for the black community and you
know let them come forth and they are
intellectuals like you know i i don't
know if anyone thinks of me as a white
intellectual but but the point you know
ed is and now you're frozen again damn
it um
can you move yeah i hear you on twitter
can you hear me eric so i can hear you
okay i hear you on twitter i don't see
you on let me uh log you back in
but the point being that we have you
know this notion of of leaders in the
field and then these leaders have some
responsibility if they're going to
accept that mantle and as christopher's
saying in the black community i mean who
can who can possibly say that they speak
for the black community as a black
intellectual etc etc and this is right
or left i'm not um i'm not uh you know
choosing sides
but um but in the context of you know of
a particle physics or string theory you
know clearly ed is a leader in in a
certain sense what does that entail what
responsibilities does he have to you
know as the de facto leader in the case
where there is no leader you know let
let whoever is willing to lead come
forward so what responsibility does ed
have
after all he's made very clear
statements about string theory including
that he believes that string theory is
the only theory of you know any form of
geometric or a theory of everything that
can incorporate the yang mills um
equations in a self-consistent manner
i hear you yeah i hear you on twitter um
let me see people hear him on
youtube let me check that out
so
no i don't hear you on
youtube
unfortunately can you talk
keep yeah keep making
making noises um
how about now does that work that works
now perfect okay
okay um well this is nonsense i don't
know how to say it politely uh edwin is
a leader as his dick as is um
david gross
um i think that nima arkani hamad is a
non-string theory leader
you find out who the leaders are by who
gets the keynotes and who um
makes decisions about uh
you know where the field is going to go
and how does funds things
this is nonsense we have to recognize we
have leadership and i don't know
why christopher sweat is in this
conversation edwin's a super important
human being who directed the field to
an enormous extent
at a time when it was lost and i think
it's really important to recognize that
we don't experience leadership in our
time
i don't know that somebody's given him
the talk that says hey
this isn't your field it wasn't
einstein's it wasn't newton's it wasn't
derock you have responsibilities you're
70 years old this year
and
you have got
to do certain things that aren't up to
you it's a it's the burden of leadership
and for some reason we're living in an
era in which nobody feels any burden of
leadership
um you know i think that for example
uh george i and glashow felt too much
burden when their
su5 um
theory was not immediately confirmed for
proton decay and they immediately fell
on their swords
well you know
as per our earlier discussion it's not
like grand unified theories went away
it's not even like su-5 went away
but this idea of in an era in which
everyone survives
making a mistake doesn't end up as a
kill shot and also your your colleagues
are decent enough
to give you credit for your work even if
there's a flaw a flaw somewhere in the
theory if there's a fly in your ointment
and i i just i don't know what planet
i'm on it's very clear that when you're
70 years old and you've spent this much
time on a theory and you've taken this
number of resources human financial and
otherwise to explore an idea and it has
this little to show for itself and by
the way i've written extensively about
all the positive externalities of the
string theorists uh you know
geometrizing uh quantum field theory and
so there's no shortage of positive
things i can say it's not it's not an
anti-them thing but
it's sort of an at what point do we
become adults
and i think that it's really important
to recognize that most of us are saying
wrong things about science to avoid
offending kumaran
and ed
uh
you know and strowman germa kulczynski
and company i think that these guys
really
probably want to get off this
train at some level think that they want
to say something
about the field needs to be open and we
made some mistakes and i don't i don't
think we need truth and reconciliation
but i think we need to be decent and i
think we need to recognize that the real
problem was string theory culture not
string theory and the reason that it was
problematic
is that it attempted to put other
cultures to the sword prematurely based
on what it said it was going to do and
then failed to deliver
so you say that you shouldn't fund them
because we're about to do everything and
then you don't do it i want to know what
can we hear more from the people who
don't work in physics anymore can we
hear more from the people
uh who you've trashed uh
i think about the bootstrap community
from jeff chu
and
i think it's really important that we
recognize that you know catastrophe
theory of renee tom didn't work out
necessarily the way we expected we've
had all sorts of big theories that you
know maybe the reggie calculus didn't
didn't go where we thought it was going
to go in general relativity whatever it
is
it's really important and necessary that
we cut this out
are we scientists or are we are we post
modern um philosophers who play with
equations i don't know yeah i want to
talk about other
possible contenders that you've been
you know particularly exciting my
attention to
first let me see
how the sound is on youtube if folks can
let us know um in the comment in the
chat section that would be very helpful
um and which microphone can you tap the
microphone
that i gave you last hanukkah
yeah so that's not working right now
so can you switch over i recommend that
we move to a more
um
tested video platform for next time yes
we can do that we can also switch to
skype on the same uh streaming service
if you like
but let's uh let's see if you can just
plug in your microphone again
uh it says that it's a little bit coming
it's coming from your laptop
um
i think i think it's mostly okay i mean
people aren't complaining twitter you
sound fine and uh
and
that's half the battle there's actually
more people on twitter than on youtube
which is kind of interesting well
youtube will be over time yeah i do have
a channel on youtube folks should know
about dr brian keating where eric has
been probably my most frequent guest and
last appeared on my 50th birthday this
past september and that was so much fun
uh to have you and i'm trying to have
them on at least once a quarter
to go over
topics of mutual interest for
myself and for eric and i think
you know hopefully for many of you out
there i also do solo videos where i do
kind of explainers about experimental
physics there's a lot of theoretical
physics out there in the world and i
love sean carroll and i love sabina
and i love brian greene and the guys at
pbs space time who i've collaborated
with but uh i think i want to you know
really kind of up the ante and kind of
production quality of those videos where
i'm explaining topics in experimental
physics not just in cosmology not just
the theoretical aspects although i will
get into theory on occasion as eric
knows i like to dabble
in theory the way a drummer down more
than music
well i'm not a profe i always say to my
students eric you know i say
you know you're an experimentalist but
that doesn't absolve you of the of the
you know necessity and burden of
understanding the theory all you are
absolved of my uh my student i will say
is that you don't have to come up with
new theories you don't have to invent
new theories
or really you know look for extensions
or corollaries to them but you need to
understand them otherwise you're just
kind of uh you know almost robotically
going through the motions and that's not
why i got into physics to train a bunch
of ai you know
uh non-sentient beings and i'm blessed
to have so many wonderful students
working with me
and and also to have in
a wonderful
a wonderful amount of high school
students uh one of which is is
particularly close to eric and i want to
get into that um and how to train a
student how do you want to train your
kids if you're interested
in getting your kids interested in stem
hit the hit the like button because eric
and i are working on a project together
with our children we're kind of doing a
swap of a certain kind
where my child will uh learn and and get
recommendations from eric in particular
about experimental physics and uh and uh
our experimental cosmology and i will
teach his son about uh you know gage no
no i'm just kidding we actually do the
opposite so i'm sort of
coaching mentoring zev weinstein who's a
brilliant talented uh young man that i'm
grateful to have some uh form of
influence with
and uh and eric is tutoring my son my
oldest son on uh you know the the most
beautiful ways to get adjusted to as a
ten-year-old can at least to get
adjusted to um to get adjusted to the
concepts of higher mathematics starting
with of all things higher dimensional
geometry topology with a book that eric
bought for my son uh recently called the
shape of space which i'm enjoying him
reading to me it's really wonderful eric
and i want to thank you for that on
behalf of my son and myself
and let's try your microphone again
okay
how does that uh sound i think it's
right yeah it's a little bit better yeah
i think it's okay
um so uh now before we pivot exactly how
to raise it
go ahead no after you i was gonna say
before we pivot to how to raise a child
uh that you're interested in becoming a
stem professional which i think we have
you know in the last six months of
working together on this project with
our children uh we have some insight
into and in particular how to do uh
things like bypass the bs kind of
introductory you know stuff that you can
get past very early on and this is risky
for me eric because i'm a public
university professor right so part of my
uh you know my lucr comes from
having students enroll for all four
years but if i can get them to bypass
your son or your daughter to bypass two
or three years i'm all for it and get
straight to the good stuff which is more
fun by the way for me and you to teach
but i want to get back to
geometric theories because you were
extremely
again you had a great year you played
old town road on your birthday at a
little nozzle before we get to that to
that let me just
go ahead and think
it's it's not really fair though um
i think that
you know what's happening with with zev
is that he more or less kicked us out
and then
invited us back in
uh
he made a study of physics uh what is
taught isn't it to undergraduates he
realized the same courses occur multiple
times
he you know he effectively came up with
an entire plan
to self-teach a physics major
and
i would love to take credit for that
except i didn't do it
um and i think you can take some credit
for it in part because you challenged
him with something where you said look
you know it's going to actually take
more time and effort to train you than
you're imagining so this doesn't become
a net positive and he's like
hold my beer yeah
before you give me a homework assignment
you know well and you know we were
locked down during covet to some extent
he said okay
what do you feel like if i take this
summer and uh
and burn it on a physics major that
doesn't exist and i said well you've
never taken calculus or linear algebra
how are you going to do that he said
uh do you believe and i said okay i'll
try
so i don't i still don't know how he
somehow bootstrapped himself into
seemingly having the i mean am i wrong
about this he seems to have more or less
the knowledge of a no it's a physics
major with some holes in it but
it's pretty much like quantum and
classical electromagnetism i think that
it's it's a wonderful thing because
it's a huge shot across the bow about
do we need to teach these courses
multiple times can we just well and and
furthermore brian one of the things
we've been discussing is um
[Music]
is the fact that you you wait until your
second year of graduate school often to
take general relativity and quantum
field theory the two
theories that sort of define
everything and they aren't even required
of every experimentalist which i had no
idea right different universities have
these different requirements so in part
i think what zev is doing
uh is essential in that if we need if we
need more time so that everybody learns
general relativity and quantum field
theory
we have to figure out how to compress
the physics major so that you can do
more more quickly
and
again i think that he wanted to impress
you that you he didn't need to be a net
drain on your time and that also sort of
inspired me with your son that when your
son gave an unbelievable math uh answer
um to a group theory problem without any
equations or any symbols that we were
able to serve up to him
uh just let's hit him with you know jeff
weeks the shape of space
which is a wonderful book which can is
really about higher topology it's kind
of an advanced concept beyond college
for most people but written in a way
that's engaging for anyone uh to read
and so i think what we need to do is we
need to use these channels that we have
in particular to get more people from
backgrounds you know you and i come from
from from jewish backgrounds which have
a reverence for learning if somebody's
coming from a culture that maybe put a
higher emphasis on the arts sports or
something like that we need to get this
stuff so it's less painful more
fulfilling and more exciting to the
imagination
so that you don't happen to you know
need to be in this game because i i
certainly didn't come from an academic
family i know that i was just going to
make the joke you know you hear a lot of
people talking about well i'm a first
generation you know college student and
i'm thinking like our kids are you know
they can't even be first generation
professor you know phds you know your
your kids have you know two harvard phd
parents and my kid has at least one you
know phd from an ivy league school
for grandparents and so yeah that's true
and same with mine yeah my mother didn't
graduate from from college until she
graduated from western connecticut
stayed at age 55 with a degree in social
work but my dad of course did now but i
do want to say we did spend time with uh
one of my best friends the best man at
my wedding stephan alexander jamming
along with our kids and and talking
physics and and drinking a little bit of
wine let's let's be honest okay uh
there's no there's no harm in drinking
that one
uh we had some roti and and steph got
some great delicacies um uh you know
that that he would used to cook for me
back when i was at brown
uh but uh but you know stefan is a
product of the public school system too
and you and i live in california and the
fact that we've had it go out of our way
you know to really craft a curriculum
for our children uh because the powers
that be won't do it is ridiculous and i
am so i'm i i've never been so disgusted
with the with the leadership that we
have and i and i said to stefan look
you're black you know for those that
don't know professor stefan alexander
he's a president of national saudi black
physicist full professor at brown
university he was the ee just
bouchet award the guy's got all possible
credentials that you could ever want
okay this man is a product of the public
school system he said i would not be
talking to you if i didn't have exposure
to calculate we wouldn't have been
friends i mean forget about like yeah he
would be a professor like i wouldn't he
wouldn't be in my life brian this is
just this is just stupid and and it's
it's important that um
it's important that we learn to say no
to people with bad ideas no matter what
color skin or what their sexual
orientation if you've got a bad idea i
don't care if you're jewish muslim
christian atheist you've got a bad idea
and the idea for example getting rid of
standardized testing in california is
completely insane this idea that math is
discriminating uh it's also
i'm just going to be very blunt about it
it's also extremely bigoted yeah how
many of our friends uh who are all for
this kind of uh this nonsense secretly
believe that black kids can't do math
and it's offensive to me it's like you
know what
they're going to be just fine
let let us at them absolutely and get
out of the effing way this is just
stupid you're not going to take the
entire
and this claim that right math is biased
against people of color
have you taken a look at our winning
math olympiad team
there's one white guy on it wow but then
they'll say oh those are asian americans
those are you know you know what i don't
have time for stupid let's talk about
smart no the thing i like to point out
is if you go to nigeria which is one of
the most advanced technological
civilizations on earth uh and and you
know just they don't teach two plus two
equals anything other than four in any
other top university so let's stop
saying it's white supremacy i can't
content countenance that well
please let me know how uh alternate
mathematics works on your tax return
let's just
you know what we we we take these people
too seriously all right so let's let's
go positive then let's talk about like
specifically what we are trying to do
with our kids and i think a lot of it
comes down to time and and this pandemic
has been a great challenge it's been
hard you know being around you know a
bunch of kids all day long and then
having to teach another bunch of kids
other people's kids uh and and doing all
and dealing with coveted tests every
single you know afternoon it seems like
there's a kova test to take care of and
and i just i just you know thought about
it but like when are we ever gonna get
this time back this is a gift like i
wouldn't probably have had time to spend
you know with with my kids let alone
your kids in in the sense that that we
have now and we've kind of developed a
little
and it's an experiment and i always say
you know people like we're experimenting
with our kids well i'm an experimental
physicist so you know f off if you don't
like experiment um i'm not expecting 200
kids since the day they were born
and and what else do we have i mean
they're going to blame us no matter what
so we might as well have some fun with
them and i think the most fun thing that
you can do is not but by the way for
those of you out there neither one of us
is pushing either one of our children to
follow in our footsteps and in that
sense i don't want them to
right it's much more durable if they
don't and and to see that's not the
issue brian the the issue is is that
they want to know what are the coolest
things in the world well well it's not a
career decision like
the ability to talk to a 16 year old kid
who has a more or less a bachelor's
degree's worth of knowledge of physics
yeah and and to have him correct me and
you know i i i didn't i didn't come to
physics through that route i went
through a totally different channel it's
it's a wonderful thing to view it as
culture and you know just because
you know you played the oboe doesn't
mean that you become an oboe player
you know
it should be the case that you can learn
quantum field theory and general
relativity and differential topology
without having to make those
your career
and we don't have a we don't have an
idea that that's possible because we
make it so difficult that by the time
you're done you want a career and you
need a career and it wouldn't be fair to
you not to have a career and i think
that in some sense that's part of the
problem is that we need to make this
much more
simple to explore the most beautiful
ideas in the world
and you know it's also a great comeback
to that whole feynman thing about you
know if if you
if you can't understand it it's because
the person explaining didn't it didn't
make it make sense right i don't
understand well but
you know they couldn't understand it
it's wonderful watching the fact that
this stuff is understandable and
watching the fact that it trips people
up in exactly the same places you know
for example you might say that
there's a hilbert space of states
you know and the the the the points in
the hilbert space are the states of the
system right and well that's not true
because you know there's an issue for
projective hilbert space or maybe it's
not really a hilbert space maybe it's or
maybe it's a rigged hilbert space there
are all sorts of ways in which we sl we
we just go
quickly over things where we're slightly
lying and it's been really interesting
watching
the
the the 16 year old figure out that
there are a bunch of lies that are told
as the you know as a scaffolding and
then the lies are removed later
it's crazy that we teach chemistry
before quantum field theory because it's
dependent on quantum filter and so you
know in a weird way i think i'm getting
a lot out of this time watching my child
teach himself
which is not the same thing as teaching
my child or teaching your child my plan
for your child was to buy the book and
to have isaac teach himself
the subject with
me getting him out of the ditch whenever
he gets into trouble but it's really the
old kung fu panda point that the turtle
teaches the panda it's not shifu who
teaches the panda it's the turtle and
they only have two conversations in the
entire film
but it also underscores this need i had
a conversation i was honored to be on
tom bilyeu
and his podcast recently and uh he's
he's very much hoping you'll go back on
his show
and he and i chatted a lot and he
doesn't have children and he made that
an intentional decision he and his wife
lisa that they weren't going to have
kids and that this is something they
didn't want the you know quite frankly a
slight burden and so forth and i said
well you know i didn't get on my high
horse about it uh but i said you know
because there are people that can't have
kids and and it's for us to say well you
could only make an impact if you do you
know kind of teach your own kids and so
but i said look tom you can be an
ideological parent just as much as a
biological parent i don't think
particular importance should be paid to
like who produced the sperm or the egg
that produced a certain king you know he
asked me like well don't you feel closer
to your to to a biological kid than some
kid you adopt i said tom you know god
forbid you know it happens that a parent
is told let's say someone comes to you
eric and says you know zev
uh he kind of looks like you but but he
was actually uh he's
mixed up at birth in the hospital you
know we accidentally mixed him up and uh
he's not your kid this happened to a
friend of mine no way he had he had five
kids no way it wasn't wasn't wasn't a
question of a mix-up in the hospital but
another uh less fortunate situation
and the child that he's closest to isn't
his yeah
and but but again
tom bilyou is doing great things in
terms of yeah
no no of course i i know we all the
usual
i am disturbed about the anti-natalism i
think it's very important that we try to
recognize that there's a reason that we
have our own biological children but
when that doesn't work out there are a
whole panoply of options uh including
mixing you know some sometimes a mixed
family with adopted kids and not up or
taking on other people's uh
children and pouring your your wisdom
into them
our friend melanie
notkin has talked about we have to talk
about something which is uncomfortable
which is that there are preferred states
of the system but there are lots of cis
situations in which you get into a
non-preferred state and it can be as
deeply fulfilling or more fulfilling and
for some reason the nuance isn't present
to talk about that but in general i
think both of us agree have babies i
will point out that the whole dem the
demographic transition from high
numbers of children to lower numbers of
children has been an incremental version
of anti-natalism as you give people
opportunity costs particularly women
they tend to have fewer children and
also of course as more children survive
they tend to uh stop having many
children expecting that some of them
won't make it but you know to get to get
back to it and sum it up yes i think
that this time of covid has been huge if
you've used it to try to not only teach
your children but have your children
have the freedom to teach themselves
while you're at home and to just watch
the process and try not to interfere too
much yeah and uh just to close out that
little vignette with respect to tom you
know i did say to him that i found it
very you know um very interesting that
he has you know made a commitment and
his decision to not have kids can only
be verified by him to have been a bad
one on his deathbed and he admits that
if i regret it on my deathbed then i
know it'll be a bad decision i said
he'll never know he'll never know and
but we'll never know but there's a side
benefit which is that i think we can
know and and one of the ways that we can
know is that we can know that being an
ideological father or mother uh is is
impactful and i think that comes down to
our kid like our kids might listen more
like zeb might listen more to me about
certain things and and about academia or
maybe an experimental physics sense and
they're just lacunae that you and i have
in our parenting and knowledge base that
they can be fulfilled by the other and i
think that's so powerful that that my
son will look like oh eric told me to do
this like i'm i'm wondering eric can you
tell him to clean up his room tonight
and put away because he's going to
listen to you he may not listen to me
but that is a very very powerful
observation i think that i'm seeing that
sometimes you need as hillary clinton uh
you know once said it takes a village i
say it takes a multiverse and to have to
have an input it just shows you the
benefit that you may not be this
person's father or mother but you could
impact them in a way that maybe their
own biological parent couldn't have
influenced them to an extent brian we do
need uncles and aunts and all that kind
of stuff i think melanie and jordan
peterson
you know trying to fulfill that's really
important but i also think that you know
we're also dancing around things that
aren't true that sound good i mean i
think the fact is is that i've watched
your five kids listen to you because you
put in the time and and you build
credibility and the way in which you
parent
and you know i do think that in part
we've gotten into this lazy thing about
teenagers they always rebel
none of this stuff is really true i
think the point is if you have really
good strong families
kids figure out that they have to both
dis ambiguate well
they're going to have to
figure out the difference between what
they believe and what you believe and
what's right for them and
their time versus your time sure but i
also think that quite honestly families
are super important and we in the united
states made a huge mistake by thinking
we could rely on the market
to take over many of the basic features
of family life and i think we're being
taught a lesson that as children come
home to live that's not failure and
that's not weird it's the fact that
families are an important um
auxiliary with respect to markets
markets fluctuate there are problems and
they're wars and it's important that
some portions of your family are strong
enough
to uh take in the weaker portions during
tough times and and help people out and
i think that these are starting to be
real real tough times i think they can
get a lot tougher than this and i think
we should be making a much larger bet
uh on families and a smaller bet on the
market as fewer fewer people i mean tom
bilyeu has been able to get the market
to work for him but most of us can't get
the market to work for us at the same
extent and i think it's really important
to recognize that um
i don't want to pretend that zev doesn't
listen to me or isaac doesn't listen to
you
they're really listening and we've got
to set an example and it's tough because
in some ways i don't think we've ever
been
told that we are the adults and so in
some sense you kind of look around the
room and you say wait wait wait me no
time to lead
and each of us with different you know
kind of like you know gaps in our own
father's upbringing but i do want to
point out one market force that's really
troubling along the anti-natalism and
then we'll move on but uh there was a
tweet over the summer by some
mathematician john carlos baez who was
at uc riverside famous guy brilliant guy
and he was saying like i'm going to
spend most of my time thinking about
like climate change and so here's a talk
i gave about climate change and in the
talk he talks about all the things you
can do to stem your carbon footprint
okay this is cool let me listen to it
he's a bright guy i mean and he goes
through the mathematics of it and it
comes out with you know don't eat meat
maybe you know i can cut back on a
couple of bosses every now and then but
it'll be tough but maybe for the planet
i'll do it um don't take so many airline
trips especially to conferences well you
know check plus i haven't been to you
know very many conferences lately
they've all been over zoom
and i don't know if that's a
particularly good thing or bad thing
we'll talk about that some other time
and then another thing is like don't
have kids or adopt
and that was the last thing and i was
like excuse me and and it's it's more
than just like a factor of five it might
be even ten times more impactful if you
don't have a kid according to john
than if you do uh then if you cut out
meat and driving uh cars and going to
conferences i was like well isn't that
logical extrapolation that nobody should
have kids and or maybe we should commit
suicide john uh like like i think that's
so fatalistic and that's so under it's
so depressing to me eric that a
scientific mind as great as his would
fundamentally i mean what if not just
the next zeb weinstein there are people
that aren't born there are many millions
of people that aren't about so are we
going to stem the possible contributions
to getting off of this planet or
bettering this planet or healing the
carbon crisis itself by not having kids
what kind of advice is this
i have a hard enough time with
self-hating jews self-hating humans is a
bridge too far i think i can't do it
especially mathematicians can
can we get on to another topic okay
let's go on tonight i don't want to talk
about about nihilism i want to talk
about uh uh what i call the assayer
project which is a a schema uh for me
hopefully with with help from folks like
you and uh luis alvarez
uh alvarez gamay at suny stony brook uh
stefan alexander and hopefully folks
like paul steinhardt although i haven't
asked him yet but we're gonna do like a
shelter island three we're gonna do
recreate these famous conferences that
really set the stage uh for the future
of experimental and theoretical uh
physics going you know from the 1940s
and 50s uh you know to the 80s i think
the last one was some time in 1980s
we're actually going to do it at you
know the rams head in and shelter island
at some point okay so uh so stay tuned
for that if these are the kinds of
things that turn you on but um
i've been noticing an asymmetry uh that
certainly your theory of geometric unity
is controversial
it's gotten you know flack and and and
so forth and we're not going to get into
that necessarily but i haven't noticed a
symmetric property wherein people a to
the extent that they'll criticize
whitten because they'll know that he's
not going to listen or doesn't even know
who they are if you know sabine or me uh
you know or you uh quite frankly if we
start you know skewering him for now
adopting the anthropic principle and the
multiverse in the landscape that's one
thing uh but but other theories of
everything uh for example peter white um
who you're uh you know uh friendly with
i know stefan is friendly with he's
given a lecture at uh at um at brown
university at stefan's invitation about
his new theory and i i just thought it
was particularly touching to me
that you had the um the as we say the
menschlach you were you were mensch you
went through his theory which you don't
necessarily think is ultimately going to
prevail or be correct and might have
some some flaws that we can get into
it's a good idea but it's more important
the meta idea is that he has the idea
and that you're taking it seriously and
i know i noticed that you're going to be
doing this thing with brian greene and
sabina and michael shermer for some
reason uh our mutual friend but um you
know talking about theories of
everything and i made a joke you know i
think we should give a nobel prize to
the person who doesn't come up with a
theory of everything but what you should
say with that's a reference to it yeah
that's a reference to the hadronic uh
resonances of the 1950s and 60s where
somebody said we should give a nobel
prize to the person who doesn't find it
come on i'm trying to steal a joke come
on give me a break we're amongst friends
here sorry sorry go on
um you know in in judaism that's
actually a great sin if you say like um
you know i'm gonna steal that line
that's called genevas das no no no no no
i was supplying the reference to show
what what an erudite i know i know you
yes exactly okay um so so getting what
do you make of this asymmetry that
people like our friend sabina or others
will will say i don't have the time you
know to uh to even learn about weinberg
sorry weinstein or wolfram or or garrett
lisi or now peter white a lot of w's in
there by the way but uh but she'll make
a music video about it you know i love
you sabine but but you know you she has
time you know it takes a lot of time to
do stuff but i want to ask you what do
you make of this uh of this lack of and
even peter white on lex friedman's uh uh
podcast not too long ago when he was uh
down there in austin texas shout out to
lex uh he might be listening um and i
was honored to go on the show and
hopefully that'll air in the near new
year but um but with lex he you know lex
asked him point blank like what do you
think of eric's theory and he's like i
don't know enough about it and it's kind
of the standard bs i'm sorry i'm a
little sick of people saying they don't
have the time for stuff i as an
experimentalist made a joke that my
theorist friends in the fifth floor of
mayor hall didn't find very funny but i
was like you could tell that the
pandemic's coming to an end this is
before omicron uh because the theorists
are back their theorists offices are
back to the usual state of of of
solitude and emptiness um meaning that
you know they they kind of do things but
we experiment unless we have to come up
with payroll and i have a half million
dollar a month payroll after coming up
yeah and and we have my friend lee
cronin is in the audience he has the
same kind of payroll we're
experimentalists we're building stuff
we're going to chile we're going to
germany we're going to uh raise funds
and the nsf in washington dc
um i said if you don't have time like
who's going to have
brian that's not it's not real
you know that it's not real all right
well tell me what it is well it's that
this is super uncomfortable i don't like
being the person who's both explaining
what's going on and the person putting
forth the theory it's not it's not fun
let's ignore gu and just say generally
why doesn't sabine look at peter white's
theory
well in general the idea is that it
it takes on some responsibility that as
you take on a theory and you start to
look at it and try to understand what
the person is doing
you might have to acknowledge oh that's
a that's a cool point that's new that's
interesting or i don't understand this
or i don't know whether it solves the
problem that the person is claiming or
seems to be claiming
and so in part
everybody's guarding their reputations
or they're attacking people's
reputations and i think it's really
important to notice that the whole point
of academics was to get people beyond
this
can't we give you a credential and vet
you enough that we can trust you
and
the situation with respect to let's say
peter white's theory right peter white
has a really interesting
idea he didn't say it this way but he
said the strong force has a collection
of symmetries that looks very very
strange it doesn't it's not
the weak force the electromagnetic force
have symmetries that are commonly found
in all sorts of systems
but the strong force has this set of
symmetries called su-3
let's make that the center piece of a
theory
and what we'll do is we'll take that and
we'll stick it inside of
something called u4 and we'll quotient
u4 by u3 we'll get the strong force out
automatically and then there'll be a
version of space time with four spatial
dimensions and zero temporal dimensions
and one with one time dimension and
three space dimensions we can we've had
this puzzle about wick rotation from one
into the other
we'll use the fact that the so4
part that looks like four space-time
dimensions has an asymmetry between its
left and its right factors
he does a lot of interesting stuff
to come up with a suggestive stylistic
picture for why the world is in part the
way it is and he doesn't go on to claim
that it's he's got three generations in
the model
of of matter
but the point is it takes
i don't know an hour and a half to sort
of really grok not only what he's doing
but why he's doing it and now i'm a part
of an hour and a half sorry i i didn't
know it was an hour and a half sorry uh
i retract my my concerns
well
you can do it a lot faster if you wanted
just a cursory overview right but yeah
in part
the real thing that nobody's saying is
we don't take any of these people
seriously if you're claiming that you're
making progress you're lying
and in fact never doing this an
experiment we would never do this in
experiments well i understand but things
have gone insane why is that don't work
is it because we value secretly value
theoretical physicists more than
experimental physicists well sure
there's a way in which we value
theoretical physics
when it works
more than we value generic experimental
physics when it works who would you
rather have on your interplanetary
rocket ship a theorist or an
experimentalist
well first of all we haven't always had
to choose we've had enrico fermis in our
in our midst right so that's true one i
don't want to get into i don't want one
more version of bloods versus crips
right
they're all welcome at my sherbets
here i'm throwing up the shin symbol
that's that right is this a gangster
shin gang yeah the most feared gang on
it okay go ahead but that's not really
what's happening what's happened is that
we've stopped believing in ourselves we
don't believe that there will be an
einstein in a post office we don't
believe that there will be a galileo
threatened by a pope
we're sort of reenacting all of these
things
this theater
and i think what you see that's really
disturbing to me is that
i i don't care for stephen wolfram's
approach but i'm certainly glad he's
doing it and i'm glad that somebody is
saying let's take the discrete more
seriously than we take
the continuum i mean the continuum to me
is the salient clue in many ways but the
fact is somebody should take the other
bet
somebody should say well maybe the
universe is more like a computer you
know not just to get money out of
silicon valley but you know because in
fact
information is a different basis than
we've had previously for trying to
understand the physical world
and what i don't understand is
by stepping out of the academy you know
i'm i can say i'm a podcast host i'm a
mathematician i wasn't even trained as a
physicist it
whatever
i'm an md
tl capital um
what's really happening is that you guys
in theory
don't believe in each other and you're
trying to take each other out anybody
who's doing an isolated thing like
wolfram or white or myself
or julian barbour or garrett lisi or
whoever
um
i can find things like you know garrett
and i have talked for for ages about his
theory i don't believe in it
it's not dumb on a bunch of different
levels
i don't think it hangs together
but the fact is is that
but your criticism of him is an act of
love it is an act of love that you are
going to take him seriously and you're
going to actually continue but it's not
just an act of love and it's it's like
the reason i tear you apart is because i
love you so much that's why you beat me
but no i'm so freaking sick of all of
these stupid twitter answers you know
it's like
anything that sounds
like sophisticated on twitter usually
fails in real life
uh i i like garrett a lot and i i've got
a lot of love for him as a team being
and we've hung out a lot i don't think
his theory works it doesn't mean that it
can't work one day they can't remove
some of these issues but i think that
stylistically
it's got tons to recommend it over one
more drone looking at kalabi-yao
manifolds
as part of a string theory program or
you know yet the the 12 millionth paper
on ashtakar variables uh you know in a
new light and and so in part and i i
think you know we actually have to note
that sabine in her older incarnation was
positive about the fact that people were
spreading out
i don't know what's happened to sabine
recently i'm very disturbed by some of
the stuff that i'm seeing but she's
historically been
that in some sense it appears to be much
more reflexive and sweeping
and i think that you know in part she
was much more cautious more careful more
subtle more nuanced and it's become kind
of the oh please uh
model and i i think that
the the first version of sabine was
doing a tremendous
favor to the field that the field did
not repay
and i think that there got to be some
bad blood and you know i watch as people
sort of go into these intellectual
um
smaller worlds because they some bad
thing happens to them and they overreact
i think it's really important to
recognize that we needed to give sabine
more love
when she was the conscience of the
community and she was saying things that
we didn't want to hear and then
gradually yeah gradually it's going to
become why should we spend money on
accelerators or why are the theories of
everything or why is it always men who
are pestering me with their grand dreams
and you know this is stupid it's not at
the same level
um as the rest of sabine's critique and
in part what i what i'm looking to do is
to say i looked at peter white's theory
because i believe in my own
and i looked at garrett's because i
believe in my own and it's not my belief
in my own theory isn't
um
you know i don't need it for a
meaningful life it's a guess it's a shot
on goal
and
all of these things are not true
some of them might have some salvageable
parts but in general these attempts to
guess what the what the fundamental
structure is are not being listened to
by anyone like i will claim that peter
white likely nobody on planet earth
almost
is really reading it taking it seriously
and thinking about it and the same thing
is true with garrett and the same thing
is true with stephen wolfram and julian
barbour maybe in wolfram's case because
there's money there there's a little bit
more and i've learned
that okay this this thing about trying
to signal that it's not all about money
doesn't actually work in a world that
believes that everything is about money
so it may be that i have that wrong as
well but i i do believe that what we're
seeing
is that people aren't trying to take
these things seriously in a positive
idiom the only thing people are doing is
they're saying
well maybe jacques destler and garibaldi
can take out garrett lisi it's like the
kill shot and i think that the kill shot
is killing
interesting science
why are you looking to dispose of people
you know
in combat we refer to this as pink mist
oh you got dragged you got owned the
pawnage is extreme
we need to get these people out of the
academy and out of the sciences uh i
should say that i once watched somebody
destroy his career over lunch by coming
into the mit cafeteria and bad mouthing
a professor named arthur matic who i
believe is now now gone
and
i was very close with a very senior
member of that department
and without getting into the details
maybe i'll do it later when i feel more
ready to
uh he told me that it was not worth it
to have
a
rotten colleague
spewing bile in a department because it
was going to have the effect of taking
down the entire department to allow that
kind of poison
at mit mathematics and i think that it's
a really interesting
cautionary tale that the old guard
understood that collegiality was a
resource needed to do research if you
don't have collegiality if you go for
these kill shots
you're not going to get anything done
because there's a level of trust if you
think about the rna tie club where you
had mostly physicists trying to figure
out the structure of the genetic code
which they failed to do marshall
nirenberg eventually did it but you had
all these great names like teller and
feynman and gamoff
and watson and crick
of course being trained as a physicist
and
they shared their ideas because they
knew there was enough for everyone and
like i don't know more than half of them
i think ended up with uh with medallions
to show for it
and
i just
i think it's really important that we
drive the anti-collegial out of the
field and let them know that they can do
something else with their lives they can
become tabloid journalists
uh they can become
uh you know professional snark uh
podcasters or something but i think it's
really important to recognize that we
have to read each other's research with
a different eye
and i do think that somebody like peter
white needs to be taken seriously and i
i'm
i'm super disappointed that he fell back
on something that he you know he's got
my number he has an idea of what i work
on he doesn't want the responsibility of
saying oh i think eric's on to something
or i think eric's full of it right uh
and
you know i think i think in the last
year
or at least
at least since april 1st 2 2021
i haven't had a single physicist talk to
me about my rash my reasons for
believing in three generations that
there are only two and there's a third
imposter generation
you can just break that out
of gu and say huh we have this puzzle
why there are three copies of matter and
you've given an explanation let's talk
about it
so what i can tell you is it's not that
we're not interested
we we've we've come to understand that
taking an interest in the physical world
as a theory as a as a pursuit is too
dangerous to your reputation you spend
all this time accumulating your
reputation
and then you're given the opportunity to
try to add new ideas
and
mostly what you're going to have is the
possibility of emulating yourself
if you do anything original and this is
crazy and i think what we have to
recognize is is that we have to restore
collegiality
by
being
minorly anti-collegial to the really
anti-collegial among us and we need to
show them the exit and we need to you
know give them
uh
you know a few a few days worth of uh
food before we put them on the ice flow
but ultimately they don't belong in our
subject because they're too costly and
they don't contribute enough when i look
at how many people are you know coming
up with with purported solutions it
can't
avoid evade my notice that pretty much
all of you folks who are engaged in this
are not you people you people
some of my best friends are but you're
not you're not per you know you're not
you don't have academic freedom you're
not tenured uh you know in other words
the people that you know i have academic
freedom yeah no no but i'm saying like
peter is not an academic he's not a
tenured professor sabine is not a
tenured professor why is peter not an
academician what no let me let me finish
uh what i'm saying is the people that
have the the freedom to investigate
these things the wittens etcetera
the ultimate are not investigating it
and the people that don't have you know
permanent positions shall we say in the
academia setting uh such as you uh peter
uh peter's uh you know he's uh he's a
lecturer he's uh he's an affiliated you
know researcher but he's not a tenured
professor as far as i also run the i.t
system for colombia's mathematics
department that's great i'm just saying
he's not a tenured professor there's a
difference i know
i'm not saying better or worse i'm just
saying garrett let's take garrett
garrett's not a tenured professor right
but all you guys who who actually have a
lot at risk in other words you're not
fully backed by tenure as am i or edwin
uh and i'm not comparing myself but just
to say that you would expect the reverse
the people that have this freedom to
take it and i've often thought that you
know in in physics it's
it's it's a it's a deep question should
we really have tenure for for physicists
i mean it's very different than you know
a journalist or some and i'm not even
saying that we should have it you know i
certainly don't think we should have it
in our in our public no we should fix
tenure
ten year meaningful tenure was taken
away from you guys in 1953 by the
american associate the association of
american universities the aau when they
backed away from their communist
professors or anyone claimed to be a
communist professor saying communists
did not deserve
academic protection right right so
basically the universities caved to joe
mccarthy in 1953
and then you guys have been not very
good at getting enough funding getting
enough insulation
to defend the universities and quite and
quite honestly i'm furious with the
professor not you in particular because
you're you're you're bold enough to have
me on which is a huge thing
the real problem is the number of
um you know i was just i was just in the
physics department at the university of
chicago and i was talking to some of the
senior people and they said oh you know
diversity equity and inclusion is like a
tax
you know and i was thinking why don't
you speak out against it if you don't
believe in it it's like oh because it's
too expensive not to pay the tax i said
well then it's a protection racket
right if you can't speak out as a
professor then you've failed
and you've failed to protect the
universities as the citadel in which we
hope to have our sense-making apparatus
so partially i'm furious that people
haven't followed the serge langs of yale
university
you know these people cared and they
would tell you to go screw off if you
came after professors
and just you know the story that i was
telling about the senior mathematician
who said we will not have
a member of our faculty who goes after
other members of our faculty and spreads
bile and poison the system has to be
defended
so my question is what is ed whitton
doing to defend
the system
from
um let's say
you know a colleague he deeply disagrees
with
uh
is he speaking out or is he quiet i hear
people speaking out in safe ways you can
you can bad mouth israel for sure that's
a safe way to speak out but i don't know
that you can easily um
you know
really really talk about what's going on
in the field and so the way i look at it
is is that
the aau started this problem the
professors have become weak we had
champions like serge lang
we haven't replaced them
it's important for example to realize
why
the eulogy for abdul salam was written
in arabic
by yuval nehman
who's a right-wing israeli physicist and
politician it's because there was a
sense in which we were all above
these things that collegiality was it
was a was a force to be reckoned with
you could beat the crap out of someone
with collegiality like ending a tenure
bid uh if you were anti-collegial
and what i see is is that we've
abandoned our culture we don't know you
know as you know judaism has a
strong prohibition against gossip yep
you know it's like blow on a dandelion
now please you know
go gather the seeds
uh
we don't defend our culture and so we're
not our culture anymore we're not the
culture of duroc or of einstein we're of
schwinger do you think that's a
reflection of the broader political
polarization i mean i was listening to i
think on lex's show with tim dillon i i
know he's maybe not a good a good friend
of mine okay good good so i don't know
your nature anyway
he makes jokes that other people latch
on to and i have to deal with the
problem that he's like i don't
understand i made a joke
yes you make a joke but then what
happens is that
the jokes become harassment by a bunch
of people who aren't really very funny
but timothy i don't know that i have a
problem with him okay so anyway i think
to lexi said something you know like in
2000 the 2000 election when uh when
there was this contested battle between
gore and bush you know i remember coming
into work and my boss and my late boss
terribly andrew lang said you know i'm
just checking to see if we have a
country left anymore and like the exact
same words were said you know like right
after the 2020 election but it was like
syria like i don't know if we have a
country anymore like how much has
changed in society over 20 years is just
insane and i wonder like i've noticed in
collegiality too when i started graduate
school in the 90s
it was normal like we were it did feel
like everything was open it was just
after kobe discovered the the fossil
imprint of the of the anisotropy and the
microwave background that was crying out
for an explanation this is kobe bryant
the famous basketball player rest in
peace rest in peace no this is c-o-b-e
you've you've got to say these come on
you you're you're proving that you're
that you're a youngster you're a gen gen
q or
you're anyway you're a gen iota anyway
uh the point being that we have this
society that is is riven
with hostility with with like these kill
shots these pawnings and and stuff but
it's in the political realm and like you
know january 6th or or you know the
country it was almost over and were
ended democracy died and dark
and like the stake seems so high and
then the joke in academia used to be
like the fights are so intense because
the stakes are so low yeah that was
always the wrong statement i think it's
wrong too because the stakes at the meta
level are couldn't be higher if we don't
if we lose the educational system
so i want to talk to you about another
idea that i've been kind of uh you know
floating kicking around in my mind
which is has to do with blockchain
and i want to just tell people eric's
wallet address are the middle 20 digits
of pi so if you want to make him a
deposit he's open
just the middle digits of pi eric okay
he's not laughing uh anyway uh the the
point being what are the opportunities
for let's say and i saw a tweet by
andrew huberman over the summer uh
something like oh look get ready for the
next uh you know thing in science it's
gonna be like look down my microscope
and get my nft and that's the next big
thing in science to fund private
research and even public research i
found that horrifying like um in a sense
that first of all we've already paid a
tremendous amount to the us government
those of us who pay taxes um for for
these discoveries and for the
laboratories and for the training of the
scientists right yeah burn it all down
is coming yeah what
excuse me
when people will not defend the
universities they will not defend our
public schools there's no moment where
some somebody in a position of authority
says enough
the new york times is not meant to be a
propaganda instrument the universities
are not meant to be indoctrination camps
science is not meant to be a
post-modernist free-for-all
um
there is
there is a concept of mustn't there are
things you mustn't do
you're permitted to do them they're
they're not necessarily illegal and it's
not a question that you shouldn't do it
like all things being equal i wouldn't
do that if i were you there's things
that you mustn't do so the most frequent
example i give is you should be allowed
to burn the flag and you must not burn
the flag
it's not it's not really well
aren't i free to burn it yep if i call
it self-expression are you telling me i
can't yeah you can but you mustn't well
where does this mustn't come from
it's kind of a first principles thing
it's part of our culture it's part of
the oral torah
if we don't start exercising adulthood
in terms of a culture in terms of
getting rid of these problems people are
taking away a very different message
which is that every institution is over
that everyone who
all there is is money
there is no concept of a compact or an
agreement or an understanding that isn't
enforceable
a lot of what's going on with the
blockchain is blockchain is is people
talking about how do you deal with zero
trust
um
so
right now what we keep wanting to show
is that everyone is bankrupt
brian you just love money you went into
physics for the money you know it's like
i i don't even know what to make of
these things no podcasting i went into
the podcasting for the last in the phone
i just had somebody today from google
tell me you know read the room eric
nobody wants to talk about ufos we're
locked down with omicron
and like
everybody says actually that's exactly
what i want to talk about
we've got
we've got this deranged
um
set of easy answers and those of us who
believe in nuance and intelligent
civic life
have to stand up and say
we're not doing this anymore we need to
create an expectation
that you can sit down at a dinner
without having somebody
uh you know pee in your food or throw a
pie in your face or try to steal your
wallet
um
and you know what what we're talking
about the entire university of
california system has gotten rid of
standardized testing
well
let me just say something about that as
a as a dyslexic as a learning disabled
guy
if you want to use that language that
was my only ticket to college i couldn't
prove
that i had a brain in my head using
grades
um
my executive functioning wasn't there i
don't even know if we used words like
that when i was in high school
so what you just did is you just took
away the dreams of a bunch of people who
are not doing very well in high school
but had one way of demonstrating that
maybe there were something called
teaching disabilities
right
and
okay so now you just took the entire
university of california why well
because people of color aren't good at
math uh
[ __ ] not only are asians good at
math i think black kids can be good at
math too yeah um the whole thing is so
confused and where were we
where did when did we stand up on mas
and say over my dead body you morons get
the educators out of education we've got
a serious problem there's way too much
ideology i think that the problem brian
is is that nobody believes in tenure
because nobody's exercising tenure
almost we had this guy abbott
invited from university of chicago to
mit right you know and then he's talking
he's uninvited
well more or less we've got to start
shutting down universities that aren't
universities and if and if if our
universities are not going to be
universities if they're not going to be
citadels of learning if they're going to
be all about
um babying wrong ideas because we're all
terrified that we're going to get called
a bigot a misogynist transphobic
islamophobic etc cetera
it would be better that we not have
these structures now when it comes to
this issue of nfts
um
yes we we had a great situation in which
the the federal government effectively
paid for universities through overhead
was a very complicated cryptic system
that was worked out that wasn't open
wasn't honest but it worked at a certain
level
and we had tenure and we had an ability
for people to earn a living and survive
now everybody is terrified that they're
going to be
disinvited de-platformed they're going
to lose their grants they've got to
submit things into this weird peer
review black box
and
the whole thing is unconscionable so my
feeling is
we need to get the best parts of the
university system out
and off of the titanic before it sinks
so titanic university is going to go
under based on the poisoning
of academic life
and it's important to recognize that
universities contain some things that
aren't done anywhere else
in our civilization except for maybe a
few institutes like perimeter or the
institute for advanced study
we've got to go rescue the best stuff
before the taliban take over the art
museus
museum and start smashing idols you know
which are which are our statues we've
gotta we've gotta
we saw this in iraq with isis it
literally happened we saw it with the
bamiyan buddhas in afghanistan do you
think this is coming from without uh to
to destroy the american academic system
from within here we are
executing a self-extinguishing program
this is like anti-natalism at the level
of a country we're not going to have
something to pass that's worth passing
to our children there may still be a
country it may still have a department
of motor vehicles
but what this country is supposed to do
is to rid itself in some sense
progressively over of its baby fat
over you know decades and decades and
become the thing that it was always
imagined to be it was it didn't start
off as a particularly just place i
actually have some sympathies with the
idea of saying let's look at the 1619 is
an important date in american history
yeah there's a lot of stuff that we
forgot but i think one of the things
that was really important is that we
forgot how this country has progressed
and how it's gotten rid of its own
immorality uh progressively almost
uniquely yeah almost uniquely amongst
amongst the western siblings i mean
fighting to end the civil war uh then
slavery i think yeah i think britain has
gotten a lot kinder as it's gotten a lot
less powerful
um
which had to do with opportunity because
i i don't you know i see i see our
mutual friend lex is in the audience you
know he he doesn't like it we're too
negative right so
let me talk about opportunities uh going
forward 2022 is upon us in about a week
uh what are you looking forward to and
in particular you know not are there
opportunities for example if there is a
way in
utilizing the blockchain or something
like that are there opportunities to
benefit uh society you know i hear a lot
about web three and i made a joke that
like uh like albert eins like i don't
know with what weapons you know world
war three will be fought but i know
world war ii will be fought with sticks
and stones and i said yeah i don't know
with what technology will be in it i
said i said web 3 i don't know what web
3 will be built on but web 4 will be
built on aol cds and uh and 25k dsl but
in all seriousness what opportunities
can can such a technology it's obviously
incredibly powerful it's huge
yeah but we're going to go through a
period right now where jack is trying to
focus us on web 2 and mark andreessen is
trying to focus this on web 3. and
part of the problem is is that web 2 and
web 3 both depend on profit to bootstrap
themselves into existence then you have
the bitcoin versus non-bitcoin version
of crypto yeah
and i think
that a lot of good can be done and a lot
of harm will be done
using the blockchain i think making
things immutable trying to use math
rather than violence eventually
math will come to resemble violence if
you consider the state is a monopoly on
violence as per weber's famous
definition of what a government is um i
think that in part you'll you'll find
people including things in the
blockchain that we desperately want to
remove but we can't get rid of we're
headed into some very weird place where
lots of good things are going to happen
and lots of bad things are going to
happen and we're going to be spun and
sold things i saw naval ravicon asked
the question can you please explain web
3 is not a
ponzi scheme because my mom is worried
that that's what i'm getting involved
with and naval said oh absolutely it's a
ponzi scheme but this time it's our
ponzi scheme every generation gets one
um which i think is just some you know
that's the american dream
i don't know i don't know how to do
the problem is whatever whatever is
going to be making people money is going
to have boasting rights until it fails
and it's like when mortgage-backed
securities
uh you know took part in was what was
called the great moderation we we hailed
alan greenspan as an oracle and as a
deity and where did that go and that's
what we're going to do right again with
nfts with the blockchain we're going to
continue to build golden idols
and each calf is going to disappoint us
if we don't see it for what it is i
guess what my concern is is that
bitcoin fixes this or bitcoin fixes
everything which is its more extreme
version
is a really dangerous idea and the same
way you know
the nfts are being sold in a cult-like
fashion
this is normal
but it's also destructive you know the
railroads were probably sold as oh my
god you're not going to believe it we're
going to be able to connect the coasts
and you'll be you know at your at your
cousins in california in days rather
than weeks okay fine
these things are needed to build the
railroads
um but then
it always comes
to pass that we come to see things in a
different light and if you're swept up
in the nft madness if you're making a
fortune or if you're about to lose one
uh it's this is sort of one thing i
think that the thing that's concerning
me
is the extent to which people are saying
oh your funding isn't working move to
the blockchain
so for example i put a tip jar um
on my twitter page
because someone told me that
micropayments were the future and i
didn't believe it
and so i've had it open for a few months
and i've made almost 30 bucks
with over half a million followers and
so
i think that this is partially nonsense
and i think people should actually open
their tip jars to figure out what
they're feeling actually i actually had
a tweet about i said well you know which
main has made you more money uh have has
it been your sub stack your uh tip jar
your clubhouse tipping or or something
or else or your and or your e8th domain
and uh basically they all add up to
about you know about zero except for the
people that are you know running it
selling to eat their domains and and i'm
not against it i think you know i look
at these things eric and i look at it as
a positivist i want to see it's cool
it's fun to do this look doing i don't
need to do podcast i mean i i'm
remunerated nicely by the state of
california uh it's fun for me to do it i
enjoy talking to people like you i
probably wouldn't have met you by the
way if it wasn't i met you a long time
ago thanks to stefan but we wouldn't
have gotten you know kind of engagement
that that you and i have and the fun
that we have um you know i wouldn't
really trade that for anything and so
but i would take it back into the
citadel if i could okay go ahead in
other words in other words i'm on the
web
uh in part because it's an opportunity
to disintermediate the gatekeepers
but you have to realize that it's a
cesspool out here
or or more thankless yeah
maybe i'll say it differently it it's a
uh
it's a bathroom in a in a gas station
and sometimes it's a little bit better
maintained sometimes it isn't when you
gotta go you gotta go
but it's not a place that you would want
to hang out if you had other choices and
i believe that if our physics
departments and our math departments if
our pedagogy if our schools if our civic
and civil society was in better shape
the constant need to get around
somebody's idiocy
i mean you know you saw it with joe
rogan interviewing sanjay gupta it was
just like trying to say no no you guys
lied that i was taking horse dewormer
it's like well but perhaps perhaps that
was a little sweet we shouldn't clarify
that
yeah right it's just like you mother f's
cut the crap you're just making
everybody distrust everything so when i
claim they're coming to burn it all down
bran i'm quite serious about it the
younger people are watching us as adults
and they're saying my god why would
anyone read a newspaper why would anyone
join a political party why would anyone
want to go to school
and i don't have great answers for them
i just think we should save what works
from something that's sinking and
what i find fascinating is that no
matter how much i talk about the need to
insulate
science with money and to make
professors rich enough that they can
afford not to go along with anthony
fauci and peter dazyk
or ed whitton right so we can get
independent minds speaking up
to get rid of this this sort of sinking
each other's theories uh not because
we're trying to actually make them
better but because it's just fun to be a
dick
i don't hear anyone coming back from the
world of people with money and it's it's
fascinating to me it's like
i don't think one person
with a 10 finger figure 11 or 12 figure
um
asset base
finds this interesting
it's not that they don't hear me they
very very often clap me on the back i
mean you personally met jim simons this
summer he personally invited you out to
to long island to spend i think he's
very interested in but he may be the
exception
he is but he he did ask me
uh do you have your own funding i mean
it's just that there's some point at
which
i have to bring
we we have stuff that's cheap
that's inexpensive
like
what what theory is relative to what it
takes to keep you uh you know amused
with your toys
theory is a tiny fraction of this that's
true we aren't even immunizing
journalists journalism is cheap
um
you know i'm not a journalist i'm not
i'm not advocating that we make
journalists rich because i'm trying to
get rich
maybe i should become a journalist to
become rich if that works
but we are not immunizing anyone we more
or less the people with fu money have
zipped their lips
or they're apologizing to china
constantly
or um
you know we have people who have real
courage
who are
advertising things uh
you know or keeping a sub stack which is
gated i always find it funny when
twitter says to me um
do you want to read the article first
and it's like well there's a paywall on
that article i tried to read it
then it says be careful things get heavy
sometimes
well yeah
yeah exactly
don't you realize people are going to
die if we don't do something this is
about you know covid and you say well
why don't we lift all the paywalls so we
can read the articles
or
can i is it okay to ask you about
jeffrey epstein and the maxwell trial
sure
okay
what do you make of that as first of all
i want to know
the
it's unlike any trial i've ever
witnessed and i obviously haven't paid
you know the logarithm of much detention
and knowledge that you have but
walk us through what what is going on
there it's it's excluded there aren't
even like court sketchers in the what do
you think is going on let me ask you a
question what do you think is going on
why is the narrative being crafted as it
is who cui bono and covadas uh what's
going on here
um
i don't think that uh
that the fact that there is
no video in the court room is is
interesting you know
that that's normal um
i think you see some very interesting
subtle subtle stuff one is that most of
what i've been hearing about
is jeffrey epstein's uh
relationships with
um
girls who are on the verge of becoming
women
and
that's important and it's interesting
but
forgive me for saying so
uh
if you take a a relatively um
i don't know experienced uh 17 year old
and a 12 year old
who maybe hasn't gone through puberty
and you say well those are the same
thing because it's all children and
something magically happens on an 18th
birthday i think you're not being
honest about the horror
i feel like what we just had is we had a
bunch of
girls in high school
who you know he shouldn't have been
doing anything with i personally believe
we can respect the 18 line without much
of an issue
but the issue isn't really
uh
pervy behavior about a rich guy with uh
high school juniors and seniors
uh i've shown pictures of jeffrey
epstein with like a 12 year old on his
lap and i've noticed that in fbi footage
of jeffrey epstein's florida place
there are pictures which are kind of
hard to see on the walls right which
have stuff in a much we're talking about
a sick sick sick human being
and
we are not talking about it in real
terms
because we're afraid
right like it's terrifying to say oh
there's a big difference between a 12
year old and a
sexually adventurous 17 year old
i know that'll be misconstrued but
honestly we don't love our kids enough
to say what's true i don't think that
we've gotten into the issue of how uh
jeffrey epstein like i tried to dig into
what how do we protect these people uh
if they're part of cia programs we just
had this release of information that
people who have been in in
child sex crimes
uh not being prosecuted by
if they're if they're members of the cia
we have some sort of an informal
structure that we need to blow up right
now i believe that this is about sources
and methods
i believe that when the intelligence
community says sources and methods there
is an agreement
effectively with our prosecutors not to
proceed
and my feeling is no you lost you ran an
enormous operation almost certainly
uh that people could trip over it was a
bad operation it was a dumb operation it
wasn't even ultimately an effective one
because it wound up in the middle of the
public square right
and right now you're intimidating all of
us and how are you doing it probably
through privilege
my guess is is that we should look at
something called investigative privilege
like attorney-client privilege how do
you keep documents out of the
public i believe that we have various
forms of privilege that are being used
in an exotic fashion i believe that we
have something called an event
deconfliction system
you should look up something called
case explorer i believe or safetynet
there are a bunch of these systems i
believe that this is what is called a
i've been told it's called a blue on
blue incident where local law
enforcement trips over something at the
federal level or that's protected
uh we we had an ap reporter ask alex
acosta what he meant by the fact that
epstein belonged to intelligence and he
gives this weird rambling answer that he
clearly prepared
um we have not seen the records from
villard house
which account for a hedge fund which i
claim never existed
i don't believe that when we say
disgraced financier that we're telling
the truth
i believe what you're watching
is is that somehow
there is there has to be a system to
keep the cia
and and
other agencies
from being discovered by local law
enforcement and
if they're undercover if they're running
a front company whatever that system is
is showing you in real time how to do
something in full view of everyone where
not that much is occurring i don't think
that the prosecution was particularly
spirited
i don't think that the allegations that
really matter which is is this state
protected
seem to be front and center i don't
really understand what the relationship
between
you could make an argument that one
member of the prosecution should have
recused
his or herself um based on connections
to the government uh that are in the
family uh i don't think that we've
talked enough about 12 year olds um and
very young people
and
i think that you're watching uh a
mopping up operation where the
information that leaked into the public
is being handled as what was one at one
time called a limited hangout
and my feeling is is that
this is probably the intelligence
community screwing up in full view of
the world and we should recognize that
when you screw up you lose rights we
should probably take power away from the
intelligence
community and whatever
this uh
this agreement or understanding to use
various forms of privilege to keep these
things out of the courts
i actually subscribe to the idea that
when it's working correctly we should be
doing this but the problem that i'm
having and i'll be very clear about
i don't think there is any reason ever
for using a 12 year old
in a compromite operation in a honeypot
as an intelligence gathering as part of
the intelligence world
and if we have to do things like that
i'd prefer that we not have countries
and just call it a wrap on the human
project
i think that what we're talking about is
i know that there is nothing that
justifies this i would prefer
that the countries involved simply cease
to exist if the only way they can exist
is to use exotic sources and methods
that have to be protected
in this fashion that look like this if
12 year old girls are being endangered
let's just call the whole thing a wrap
yeah i couldn't agree with you more uh
before we wrap up we have to wrap up in
about 15 minutes i'm being told by
higher powers down here uh and i know
you've got things to get on too i want
to thank you so much for your time but a
couple more topics uh looks let's talk
about inflation i'm talking about
inflation i want to talk about covid and
uh fauci and collins and uh
and i want to talk about um
what what this year meant to you and and
highlights uh from this past year and
what you're looking forward to in 2022 i
want to end on a high note okay
all right so you know witnessing all the
great stuff that you went through and
maybe we'll have to you know defer some
of those to the next quarter let's let
maybe we can have a dedicated talk about
inflation and the economics um a lecture
series that you gave i'm just worried
that the world
is going to be subjected to
something very brutal
and i really want to
alert people because i don't know when
we're going to get to it
that uh
the calculation and uh understanding of
inflation does not belong to economists
um
i've heard you say that what does that
mean is this boskin's command what is
this
well let me let me just say this
i i don't believe that uh virology
belongs to virologists right now i'm
very often forced to wear a face mask
check myself constantly my entire life
has been disrupted by a virus you let a
virus get out of a lab potentially then
you lied about it potentially in the
lancet you got multiple nobel prize
winners to act as if we're all racist
for asking the questions fu get out of
the way this virus belongs to us all
right we have to act recognize that it's
not and possibly suppress the suppress
the vaccine for political reasons a
month before the election i i don't even
want to get into it's ridiculous
the calculation of inflation does not
belong to economists there's nothing in
it that if you have calculus and you
have a certain amount of linear algebra
you can understand what it is
and right now for example the entire
bureau of labor statistics i believe
has claimed that it's moved to a cost of
living framework which has to do with
saying i need to know how much you like
coffee relative to tea so that i can
figure out what your inflation is if
coffee becomes more expensive and he
dominates
well that's it's different than hedonics
then they said oh we don't actually have
to compute your tastes and your
preferences because of work of a guy
named erwin dewort or dyework
and you look at his work
um he's confused by the bohm aaronoff
effect
in other words he makes a statement
there's something called the walsh
multi-period circularity uh test which
is basically going around the eschers or
penrose stairs
right and you can count that how many
steps you go up when you by the time you
come back you don't actually come back
to the same level
uh this is
known
uh from
physics it's known from from
differential topology and differential
geometry to be a real effect
and the person that we're betting our
entire calculation of inflation on in
some sense is a guy who doesn't
understand that there's something called
the
ambrose singer theorem which states that
you should not expect things to come
back to normal once you've gone around
as a circle you can you can look at this
in terms of the quantum hall effect or
berries phase this is
we all get this
the economists are confused
and just the way you know sometimes you
need biologists to enter linguistics uh
to figure out well which languages are
really related to each other we used to
think that turkish was related to
finnish it turns out not to be and you
can use genetic analysis in part to sort
this out
um
you're saying i am a turk yes for my
turkish friends in the audience yeah
yeah okay
um
then
you have a situation i didn't understand
why you were doing it um
then you have a situation uh
you know in which you have to enter a
different field the physicists had to
enter molecular biology
um
well the economists have been entering
all sorts of fields using what they call
economic imperialism which they've
decided is a good thing they say that
we're the only science we're
mathematical you can hold us up to
scrutiny okay i claim that uh
you've bet the entire calculation of
inflation on the work of a guy named
irwin diwart or dewort who does not
understand that the walsh multi-period
circularity test is negated by something
called ambrose singer holonomy right
we've got to get involved and take this
stuff away from the economists until
they actually understand what it is that
they're doing because what they're using
this for
is discretion
you can change the baskets of goods you
can change the formula that you're using
to compute things with to get any value
you want you want to rotate energy and
food in or out you want to decide that
you know maybe hedonic adjustments
to quality are larger or smaller the
more discretion the economists have the
more we are in danger
of having our rates of inflation dialed
up and dialed down to values that are
convenient and particularly at a time
when the money supply has expanded and
exploded by the way interesting that we
exploded the money supply just at the
moment we changed the reporting for the
series so that if you mention that m1 is
exploded people
who are trained in universities will say
oh you can't go by that because they
changed the series
construction so whenever you're going to
change something dramatically in real
life
change the formula that you use to
construct your series at the same moment
and all of the people with master's
degrees will come to your defense
that nothing can be said at all it's
just an amazing feat right now we have
the fed commanding that money be printed
and we also have the bureau of labor
statistics with way too much freedom to
report what the effect of that inflation
is and so my claim is is that people
like us have to get involved in this
and not
you have to be prepared to say to a
thousand economists you're wrong
go read the ambrose singer theorem you
don't know what you're talking about
um so pivoting to a less controversial
subject kovid
so over the summer i coined a term for
you a nickname
a gnome de ger a num de plume
that you're the atomic clock uh that you
are right more times a day than the
atomic clock
um now you know sometimes when we're on
the basketball court okay clearly you
haven't talked to my wife but okay
that's right uh whenever somebody
introduces me for a talk you know and
it's like my wikipedia biography or
something i would say yeah thank you for
my mother for writing that entry and now
for the rebuttal my mother-in-law
she's actually a very lovely and and
loving person um kovid
yep let me see um we talked about we
mentioned a virus already
you've been saying longer than anybody
even including your brother uh that this
had all the patterns of a
of an intentional
byproduct of maybe perhaps benevolently
intended research but you know the road
to hell is paved with good intentions
right but this clearly seemed to and
this is back in 2020 early 2020
um what what have you you know besides
the awful kind of you know uh human
costs that we've endured
and accelerating and now with this new
new variant like variants aren't going
to keep popping up um but but tell me
like how have you is there one person
you know people are always asking me
when's eric going to have the portal
back on i always say like i hope never
because you know that that means more
people will come and watch them on my
podcast but but i'm just kidding about
that but if you had one guest
you know that would come on who would it
be who would you most like to talk to to
get the straight truth about it would it
be you know pfizer you know ceo would it
be eric topal would it be anthony fauci
francis con who
has the answers or can at least shed
some light and not just heat because i
know you'd be respectful but who would
you most like to talk to about
it's an interesting question it would
very likely be somebody
well let's look at what i did do i
contacted mark potashney
who's that
exactly
not everything that happens happens on
the podcast circuit and so one of the
dangers that we have is it's like
okay would it be peter mcculloch or eric
topel or
peter tia and like all those people have
tons of knowledge but
um
mark potashney
who wrote the genetics switch
on phage lambda and t4 bacteriophage i
think
um there's a giant in the field um and
he's one of these guys who's just
completely irreverent doesn't give a
crap he put me in touch with the uh
i guess the one of the discoveries of
mrna early on in this so part of the
problem is is that there is this podcast
circuit
and i mean that is a framing device not
literally but yeah no i appreciate that
but i also worry that we're all
susceptible to the idea
that we keep having the same people on
air who are public facing
um you know we both commented that ed
whitton i think did only one podcast
that i'm aware of uh maybe he's done
more but he did um the universe speaks
in numbers with graham formello who's a
guest in your program and
you know he's the big dog um i would
love to i would love to see more nema in
the world but nima's working hard on
what neem is supposed to be doing he's
supposed to come on to my show next year
but we'll see
inshallah so the problem
the problem is
i think that what we really need is
virologists who are not cowed by anthony
fauci we need people with independent
money
and i think uh one of the reasons i
picked mark tashney is that he um
i think he bought a stradivarius after
he founded a biotech company that did
well and he learned to play the bach
double violin concerto when he was like
over 40.
remarkable guy
very very honest brutal uh
in defense of science
so
my concern is that if you take what just
happened with peter mcculloch uh on joe
rogan and some of these debunkings of
him and
i think it's disgusting i think what you
have is you have
a group of people
there's no way peter mccullough is a is
a whack-a-doodle who knows nothing about
anything i i listen to how much
information he has
i can tell when somebody has a ton of
knowledge he may not be entirely
truthful and he may say some things that
are
very inferential and very dangerous and
even irresponsible
but i found the problem is that what he
did was extremely informative and
extremely irresponsible at the same time
and there's this whole thing about pick
a side why are you sitting on a fence
it's like
who taught dialectics
were they sick that you know and there
was a substitute teacher who taught
fence sitting like is it the thesis or
is it the antithesis which is it it's
like shut up
um what you have is is is that i want to
listen to peter mccullough and i also
want to listen to nick christakis
who are very bitterly opposed to each
other because in part what people are
doing is they're taking their
responsible commentary
and they're doping it with irresponsible
inference and almost everyone is doing
this i'm not positive to brian that we
aren't
you know there's only so many times i
can say fund your fund your scientists
and insulate them sooner or later i'm
going to say something crazier
right
because nobody's listening right and i i
really believe that what's happening
with kovid is is that we need to get
fauci and dasic
out
this is another one of these things that
is almost certainly inferentially
to be some sort of a workaround we
signed the geneva convention on
biological weapons i think in the 70s
we've needed a work around because we
have to protect ourselves defensively
but we're not allowed to work on this
stuff offensively and offense and
defense look the same
so is it any surprise that there's like
a really weird
infectious disease vibe
that combines kindly doctors with
bedside manners trying to keep us safe
uh with people scouring the planet for
the most
dangerous stuff and weaponizing it
telling us it is also to keep us safe i
think if people will look at the eco
health alliance and peter dazek who's
blocked me on twitter uh you will see
people again i don't hate them i don't
my guess is that they're part of a
program and that program has failed
right it might have had legitimate
origins you know
but it may have had cryptic or it's like
i'm not against crips in the state but
my feeling is is that
somebody needed to understand that
cryptic behavior on behalf of a
government has to be at an entirely
different level if you're going to do a
keystone cops clown show in the wuhan
institute of virology
while you know invoking all of our nobel
laureates to tell us that anyone who
questions this is a racist because
anthony fauci is science itself and
francis collins needs to play the guitar
poof coronavirus came from overseas i
mean it's as bad
it's like i'm 56 years old i would be a
better head of the nih or you or we
could just pick my son or your son at 10
years old i don't want people that we
can't trust
you know at any level now i personally
would not want that kind of a position
people always ask me will you run for
something it's like no i'd rather recuse
myself but at this point brian some of
us have to lead and we've got to say
that this isn't science because science
is taking it on the chin i think that
you know we're in a bad marriage with
public health public health has been
running up our credit card like crazy
and i think it's time for a divorce and
we need to say
you know baby here's your half of the
community property
go on keep spending the weekend the
books you get the lambo
right whatever and get the hell out of
my house because i'm trying to do other
things and i think that the problem that
we have is is that
too much of public health is a gold
digger when it comes to science it wants
all of science's respectability it wants
science's respect but it's not willing
to put in the hours it's not willing to
to actually understand well how did
science get to this position of respect
it's time for us to say that the
educators are not basically
scholars
and public health people are not
scientists
and where we are is in a terrible
situation where
for the most part we have two stories
that don't contain all the truth there's
sort of the crazy pandemic story which
is filled with almost certainly
conspiratorial nonsense but gets right
all sorts of errors that we've made
probably in a covert bio weapons program
which isn't that surprising um probably
around the idea that uh
we put too much stuff um
on chinese supply chains that needed to
be inside of the u.s a giant failing of
economists who didn't notice
that uh supposedly efficient things
don't aren't efficient when you're
having your geostrategic rival
manufacturer your essential commodities
we we've had a colossal failure of the
previous leadership
and
i think we need to recognize that we now
have the right to investigate whatever
we were using
to shield ralph barrick and peter dezek
it's like maybe maybe we shouldn't have
shielded them at the beginning maybe
things were working but when you have a
screw-up this colossal we need to
investigate the lancet what happened to
one of our most respected journals
and
i guess that's my my biggest concern is
that we're going to have these battles
did you see peter mccullough on rogan
well did you see chris saccas on sam
harris
it it's a it's embarrassing and and both
of those guys have truth and we have to
recognize that it's our job to come up
with the synthesis
yeah it'll be a battle over podcast uh
conducted not by by telegraph but let's
get some people who are not podcast
guests who are extremely disagreeable
very very honest and highly respected in
the world of virology particularly older
people who are at the end of a career
who grew up in
fu intellectual capital that's right
or who don't have that much time left
mark's old
and you know he's always been courageous
and my claim is let's look at the people
for example who ran to the defense of
margot o'toole when she was being
savaged by david baltimore at mit let's
see if any of those people are around
and let's get back
to people who are willing to take risk
on behalf of younger colleagues reclaim
it
okay we've talked about january 6th
we've talked about crypto apocalypse
we've talked about fouchy and kovid
we've talked about
awful things in the maxwell case um now
i want to pivot to a hopeful subject
something um something helpful the
silurian genocide of 1916. um can we
talk
i'm just kidding that's a that's a
plateau on the surface of mars
speaking of mars and speaking of uh the
next uh the next year that's approaching
us rapidly
approaching at the speed of one
dimensional time eric will get that
reference not many others out there will
but
uh what are you looking forward to let
me recap your year as i saw it as a as a
maxwell demon appearing in not the
jizelaine maxwell gillen max how do you
i don't even know how you say it
okay i hope i hope to go through life
never knowing how to pronounce that i
saw you doing many things this past year
starting off with uh with tremendous you
know public kind of
influence as a um
both through your you know
massive followings on clubhouse and
elsewhere you got me onto it
one night in your backyard
early on in the year helping consult
with with many people working through
very serious issues and becoming one of
the most popular people on that platform
and then later on the spring april
fool's day i had you on uh you did some
other guy named joe's podcast as i as i
understand it but yeah but you came out
after that you got the april first i got
the scoop
and uh and that was a huge
accomplishment and i was glad to have an
honor to have a tiny tiny microscopic
role in it but but giving you
encouragement to continue that project i
think it's incredibly valuable
then a few months after that you've got
really the world's attention
fixated on this issue of uaps both from
the perspective of perhaps
trans-dimensional uh teleport you know
travel but also for the interest and and
actually
care as you have for the military and
and to take this seriously and people's
you know people's lives and hearts and
so forth are at stake um soon after that
your birthday uh you were playing guitar
on stage in front of you know the ice
house i believe uh playing never
happened
playing glass house the glass house
playing uh old town road by our friend
uh little nas x on stage uh and then
later on in the year uh
just contributing in in so many
different ways giving lectures at
chicago and physics and economics how
many people have done that
and uh so it's a great year for you and
i'm just i'm just wondering you know
uh
how do you top it what are you looking
forward to in 2022 it's gonna be a big
year for you for me for our families
what are you looking forward to next
year
connection
hmm explain
i think that one of the reasons that um
you know i keep wanting to restart the
podcast in various ways and i guess i
keep thinking please don't it'll hurt my
rating i'm just kidding
i keep thinking
don't people realize that this wasn't
about a podcast it was i mean like i'm
trying to hide behind being an
entertainer but it's like we have to get
up off the couch we got to do a bunch of
stuff and i think people found that it
was entertaining and i was happy because
it was it was supposed to be
entertaining but it was supposed to be
inspiring it was supposed to inspire
people to
you know
like your money is about to be inflated
away by the fed are you going to do
anything about it
your government may hold information
about uh ufos
do you want it
you have a situation in which
our children are imperiled by state
protected pedophiles if i'm not mistaken
hey dads pit forks what do we think
torches i'd be up for it
um standard testing and and calculus and
algebra for and so all i hear is that
you know it's supposed to be uplifting
but we'll get to the uplifting part but
what i hear is the the mouths of
termites chewing through
uh
our shared infrastructure like
the the planet that we live on
as a house is being i can hear the
termites in the drywall
and
i'm trying to say we really need to do
something people are like okay eric what
are you going to do so what i'm really
looking forward to
is connection
like i i know for example
that if somebody told me hey i know why
there are three generations of matter i
was like how sure are you i'm not quite
sure how sure i am well let's talk about
it that's more interesting than what did
kim kardashian do last week uh in her
relationship with pete davidson i don't
care
oh kanye's gonna be mad i don't care
i i don't know
why we are wasting our time on
interpersonal nonsense when we can
connect on things that can save us
and
i think that what i'm
really interested in is trying to
understand how to connect
more meaningfully with a smaller number
of people
and i thought the podcast might be that
and i've gotten unbelievable people to
come through and a lot of people have
put in a lot of work and done beautiful
things and i i want to thank them
uh and maybe i should do some individual
episodes for that please do start with
let's start with a hebrew astrophysicist
from san diego
okay but but i think that
what we really need to do is to listen
to each other and that's why i've been
listening to uh and you know let me just
say something really positive
when i went to the university of chicago
to lecture in the economics department
um
there was some guy on twitter who's an
economist at yale who said uh wow eric
weinstein paid uh to um
to lecture at chicago
and pay me when you lectured here well
the guy in the talk who was the most
like the guy was writing me the hardest
um this guy named harold oolig
and he was also the guy who the next
morning was adamant that i meet with him
because he wanted to actually understand
well what is it that we've done
and
i think that the biggest detractor or
the biggest critic
in real terms not
twitter critic and you know just like
being a jerk
is going to end up being potentially the
biggest supporter of the theory because
it was an important and meaningful
connection
and i think one of the things that
really encouraged me was the how serious
people at chicago are
in particular the econ department i know
that they took a lot of heat for
inviting me yeah i put two papers uh up
on their uh money and banking workshop
page
unfortunately i took my wife off of one
of them
because of just how nasty so-called econ
twitter is and if you want to know why
women disappear from academics just look
at the amount of bile that was spewed
trying to suppress me which didn't work
i am really excited about the university
of chicago
and i'm excited about the university of
austin yeah they've taken some lumps and
people like oh my god you're
pink or defected and zimmer left you and
it's like okay maybe maybe it doesn't
even work
but i'm excited about people who to use
the old theodore
roosevelt line or the man in the arena
the people who are taking the risk to do
something positive that's not the case
and i well critic a good critic is a
constructive one but now we've developed
this new thing about like well you won't
face your critics well no um
i won't face mike tyson as a boxer
either you chew off one ear you cease to
become a boxer i think that what we need
is to connect to become collegial and
what i hope to do is to figure out what
i did wrong um not finding
the right people i think maybe take this
behind a paywall maybe take this
uh someplace which is smaller i like the
idea of having a large audience but i do
notice that i said in tim ferriss's
podcast that you should only want to be
famous to about 3 000 people right well
chosen i so i think that the the thing
to do is to connect and i think people
like lex and by the way my brother i
think was very early being public about
the covid coming from a lab so i think
that brett has tried to be very
courageous he's gotten super chewed up
and i think that people need to defend
the people who've stood up for you
joe stands up for you brett weinstein
stands up for you all sorts of people
are standing up for you and they're
getting bloodied and so i think what i
want to do is i want to connect and make
these things meaningful and i think you
and i
are going to try to figure out how do we
restore the scientific process
where people talk about speculations
then they talk about instantiations we
test the instantiations with data and
theory of its own for coming from
experiment
and then we come to actually conclusions
and in order to do this
my goal is to rid the world in part
of what is destroying collegiality and
civility particularly within the
sciences and then expand it from there
well i love that
notion of connection in fact lex and i
spoke about this when i was on this
podcast hopefully that'll come out in
early 22.
and i said you know the meaning of life
for me is to make to build things
that would devastate you were they taken
away and i gave the example of you know
a parent
you know once once once you're a parent
there's an infinite number of ways that
your life could be made infinitely worse
and there's a finite number of ways your
your life could even be made 10 better
right i mean your daughter gets married
or you know whatever or you get you win
the lottery and you know you have fu
money okay there as i've said before to
you you know jim simons only has one
yacht okay he's and and he's lost two
children
and i think it's incredibly important to
think about this kind of notion of
connections are those things that even
if you don't have kids that if you
envision they were taken away from you
how devastated would you be and i think
you did that with the portal and you do
that and i i think you need to to bring
it back in some incarnation or another
and not just for for personal reasons
but i do feel like you i really
appreciate that you're making this deep
huge impact that that very few people
can have and i think to to those of whom
much is given much is expected as as the
good book says and that is the you know
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy anyway
my friend it is late uh we've been doing
this for a while i want to ask everybody
who's listening
on my youtube channel to subscribe to
eric's youtube channel and then follow
him on twitter
whoever else uh you may find him
clubhouse and uh elsewhere and if you're
following eric if you'd give uh give my
channel a view that would be worthwhile
too i have a
big big plans for my channel in the next
year as well as my educational um
endeavors and my
first deployment of the first
instruments in the simon's observatory
you're not going to want to miss that
contributing to our understanding of the
evolution composition origin of the
universe and possibly maybe other
universes we'll have to talk about that
next time and you're going to be doing
something with theorists to advance this
idea of a healthy connection between
theory and physics
experiment that's right yeah so i call
that the assayer project where we'll be
examining using bayesian and other
inference methods to understand uh how
much credulity how much influence how
much uh conversation and connection that
we should be making between
experimentalists and theorists and
there's a tremendous amount of exciting
things coming out i've had already
recorded a great interviews with harry
cliff and with um with reinhard guentzel
winner the nobel and jocelyn bell
burnell who lost the nobel prize about
where we can go as a scientific
community
to best make progress with the limited
amount of time resources energy and
so forth that we have so for now and do
think uh on a on a cloudless night
about looking up at the stars and
realizing that they don't know anything
about twitter
or instagram or snapchat
and how many things we are now fenced
out of that potentially
if we were able to change our physics
picture might go from being impossible
or wildly improbable
to doable
it doesn't have to be science fiction
start dreaming again and if you have
dreams that you think might actually
matter and you're a little bit worried
about being too earnest in public and
get over it and let me know whether or
not i should bring back the podcast and
what you would want to see on it and
whether that's something that's
important to you yeah leave a thumbs up
on the video if you think eric should
revive the portal
yes and for now i'm wishing everybody a
wonderful journey into 2022 healthy safe
end of 2021 and merry christmas merry
christmas and shana tovah happy new year
to everybody out there we love you all
and uh thanks for joining us on this
little uh trip around the sun for this
past year and look forward to many more
in the future good night everybody thank
you for all you did over the last year
yeah i love you eric bye love you too be
well